Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ist ja noch gar nicht der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Wir dachten wir machen es mal alles ein bisschen flexibler. Heute ist das Chaos Radio auf Fritz nicht am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, sondern eine Woche früher, 23. April 2008. Chaos Radio 134 mit dem Chaos Computer Club mit Konstanz und mit Frank. Hallo. Ich bin Jakob Kranz und wir haben jetzt noch knapp zwei Stunden, eine Stunde, 52 Minuten, um genau zu sein, Zeit mit euch zu schnattern. Wir würden heute gerne das Thema soziale Netzwerke aufmachen. Ja, die ganzen MyFace, Spick, Ink, VZ, book.com, Communities, wo man Bekloppte treffen kann, Freunde treffen kann oder auch Leute treffen kann, die vielleicht irgendwann Freunde werden oder die besser niemals deine Freunde werden sollten, wo man komische Fotos von sich im Netz findet oder aber selber reinstellt und dann später irgendwann vielleicht den Personalchef oder der Freundin oder dem Freund oder in vielen vielen Jahren irgendwann den Kindern mal erklären muss, wie denn diese Fotos ins Internet kommen und diese komischen Texte, wer die dann da reingestellt hat. Was macht ihr da eigentlich in den Online-Communities? Wofür benutzt ihr die? Wie bestimmen die euer Leben? Habt ihr da Sorgen wegen Datenschutz, wegen gehackter Profile, wegen Geschichten wie Personalchefs, die später mal bei Bewerbungen drauf gucken? Macht ihr euch da einen Kopf oder sagt ihr euch, ist uns egal? Darüber können wir heute reden. 0331 77 97 110. Das Thema im Chaosradio heute auf Fritz. Wir freuen uns auf eure Anrufe und haben aus den letzten Tagen so ein bisschen Nachrichten-Weltung zusammengetragen, die die kritischen und positiven Ereignisse in den Social Networks zusammenfassen. Teil 1.
Bild-Cloud-Foto von Beinar-Crash-Piloten bei StudiVZ. Nachdem Beinar Unglück auf dem Hamburger Flughafen druckte die Bild-Zeitung auf der Titelseite ein Foto der Co-Pilotin, inklusive Angaben aus ihrem StudiVZ-Profil ab. Ohne Erlaubnis der Betroffenen. Bei der Boulevardpresse hat man Social Networks als ergiebige Recherchequelle entdeckt.
Die Geschichte war bei dem großen Sturm, der in Deutschland war. Das habt ihr vielleicht in den Nachrichten gesehen. Da gab es die Landung von einem Airbus auf dem Flughafen in Hamburg und dieser Airbus ist auf einer Landebahn runtergekommen. Es gab eine Seitenböe und der Airbus ist mit der Tragfläche quasi ein Millimeter vor der Landebahn, hat er sich schräg gestellt und dann hat der zweite Pilot oder der Pilot eingegriffen, hat das Ding wieder gerade gezogen. Da möchte man nicht drinsitzen, wenn man das von draußen schon sieht und die Zeitung mit den vier großen Buchstaben hat dann das StudivZ-Profil der Co-Pilotin sich genommen und hat sich daraus eine Story gebastelt, wo die Pilotin garantiert nicht drüber nachgedacht hat, als sie ihre ganzen Fotos netz gestellt hat. Frank, weißt du, was das für Fotos waren? Was das für eine Story war?
Ne, das war einfach, ich bin da auch nicht so in der Boulevardpresse bewandert. Das war einfach das Foto aus ihrem Profil, aus diesem sozialen Netzwerk und noch ein bisschen was über ihre Hobbys, Interessen, Cheerleading oder sowas war dabei. Also eigentlich ziemlich unverfängliche Sachen. Aber wenn es halt gerade keine wirkliche Story gibt, dann baut man sie halt und so ein soziales Netzwerk, so ein Profil ist natürlich ein gefundenes Fressen. Also zumal, wenn man dann aussieht, was für Freunde noch da waren. Ich kann mir also schon einen ziemlich guten Überblick verschaffen, was denn nie für ein Mensch war.
Je größer diese Netzwerke werden und je größer natürlich auch die, ich sag mal so der soziale Druck von Freunden und Leuten rundrum ist, zu sagen, ey, so mal, da bist du nicht, musst dich da online anmelden, wir wollen uns ein bisschen treffen. Umso öfter tauchen natürlich auch die negativen Seiten, die Datenschutzprobleme zum Beispiel von diesen Netzwerken auf. Gibt es da jetzt schon Erhebung, Statistiken?
Nein, man kann sagen, dass das größte soziale Netzwerk mit Abstand MySpace ist. Also der amerikanische Anbieter, der schon weit über...
Nutzer-mäßig, oder?
Ja, wenn man die Anzahl der Profile sieht. Das sind also bereits über 100 Millionen Nutzer.
Also wir hatten kurz vorher darüber geredet, es ist nicht mehr schon so lange, dass es nur so eine Musiker-Treffplattform ist, wie es ja immer mal wieder hochgezogen wurde.
Nee, MySpace hat eigentlich mittlerweile alle Interessengruppen. Es war früher so eine Plattform, wo sehr viel Musik zu finden war. Einfach Leute, die keinen Plattenvertrag haben, aber ihre Musik an den Mann bringen wollen. Heute ist es weit größer. Wir hatten zahlweise, wie ich aus Großbritannien kenne, 25.000 neue User am Tag. Die Anzahl ist eine Zeit lang exponentiell gestiegen. Es ist auch ein bisschen abgeflacht, aber die Anzahl ist schon hoch. In Deutschland ist sicherlich die größte Plattform StudioVZ, die auch schon positiv wie negativ in den Schlagzeilen war. Wenn wir nachher noch mal genauer drauf kommen. Eine andere große ist natürlich auch Facebook mit sehr vielen Usern. Von all diesen gibt es immer wieder schöne positive Berichte, wo man sagen kann, hier finden sich Gruppen mit gleichen Hobbys, hier finden sich Leute wieder, die sich in der Schule gekannt haben, hier können Leute flirten, chatten, Instant-Messaging austauschen, Bilder austauschen. Aber auch aus so einer Fälle, wie wir jetzt eingangs hatten, dass jemand das Profil abruft. Darüber wollen wir heute eigentlich sprechen. Ich persönlich würde auch gerne wissen, was für die Zuhörer die Killer-Application ist.
Was ist die Killer-Application?
Ja, was ist eigentlich das Feature bei diesen sozialen Netzwerken, was sie wirklich anzieht, was sie richtig sexy finden, weswegen sie eigentlich Benutzenden sind.
Und wo das große Drama passiert, wenn sie dann plötzlich mal weg sind oder ausfallen.
Genau, sie sind wirklich vermissen worden. Denn in Deutschland ist es so, dass man sagen kann, zwischen dem Altersgruppe von 13 bis 17 Jahren haben wir bereits drei Viertel aller jungen Leute, die ein Profil haben. Das ist also absolut normal. Wenn man heute in eine Schule geht, dann will man feststellen, dass ganze Klassen in denselben Netzwerken hocken. Klar.
Wir hatten gerade eine Serie von einem Kollegen von uns, der Johannes, der hat sich aus diesen ganzen Netzwerken abgemeldet, nur um zu gucken, wie das so ist. Und das ist eine Woche durchgezogen. Ihr könnt die ganzen Beiträge übrigens auf fritz.de nachhören. Die stehen da alle drin, könnt ihr euch in Ruhe noch mal reinziehen. Das ist sehr, sehr lustig. Weil es passiert in so einer Geschichte, dass ihm seine Freunde am nächsten Morgen so irgendwie anriefen und sagen, ey, sag mal, wieso bist du nicht online? Kannst du mir schnell mal die Hausaufgaben irgendwie mit ICQ rüber schicken oder per MSN? Und er sagte, du, ich behaupte nicht mehr. Und die haben ihn unglaublich angeguckt. Dann haben sie gesagt, wie, du hast das nicht mehr? Also, warum? Ja, brauche ich nicht. Ich kann auch mal andere Sachen machen. Ich gehe halt mal Eis essen oder raus.
Wie raus.
Und dann hat das eine, dann haben sie das auf dem Schulhof komisch angeguckt und dann hat er den Spieß umgedreht und ist sozusagen im Real Life Leute gruscheln gegangen. Also, ist überm Schulhof und ist denen um den Hals gefallen oder hat sich irgendwie sein Zitat aufs T-Shirt gedruckt oder Leute begrüßt mit Sternchen, hallo Sternchen. Das ist eine sehr interessante Kiste, wie sowas funktioniert. Das könnte auch Thema in der Sendung heute sein, im Chaosradio auf Fritz, über das wir mit euch reden wollen. In welchen von diesen ganzen Netzwerken, Communities, wie man sie auch immer nennen mag, seid ihr? Warum ist es genau die? Was ist das, was euch da begeistert, wo ihr sagt, genau da muss ich sein und wie wäre es jetzt mal nur drüber angenommen, wenn das alles weg wäre? Also was würde sich in eurem Leben verändern? 0331 70 97 110 Chaosradio auf Fritz, das wird eine sehr spannende Sendung und Frank hebt schon wieder die Hand. Ich schnappe das schon wieder.
Ich wollte noch eine Anmerkung machen zu den Zahlen. Man muss ja auch mal schauen, es sind auch ganz, ganz viele Karteileichen dabei immer. Das heißt, es sind Leute, die sich da einmal angemeldet haben und gesagt haben, das ist doch nicht so interessant.
Okay, also wenn wir 100 Millionen MySpace-User haben, wie viele Aktive gibt es da?
Na, wir können es eigentlich recht genau sagen, denn wie er allgemein im Internet bekannt ist, durch die vielen Blogger, sind ja bei Studi4Z mal so die Daten abhandengekommen. Das heißt, wir wurden im November, Dezember 2006 mal alle Profile durchgecrawled. Und so kann man sich einen guten Überblick verschaffen von den damals knapp über eine Million damaligen Profilen. War etwa die Hälfte tatsächlich aktiv. Das heißt, sie waren in irgendeiner Gruppe und hatten ein Profil, das nicht nur aus leeren Feldern bestand. Etwa 50% natürlich haben die Anbieter, wie jetzt MySpace oder Studi4Z, natürlich von sich weisen.
Da gibt es übrigens auch eine ganz gute Statistik noch zu. Da hat sich jemand die Mühe gemacht, diese Profildaten mal alle auszuwerten und es auch mal grafisch darzustellen. Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel auch interessante Häufungen bei bestimmten Studienfächern, die die Leute angegeben haben. Und da können wir auch diese Zahlen mit diesen Karteileichen und wie aktiv die Leute sind oder wie ehrlich sie sind. Kommt da ziemlich gut rüber.
Hagen Fritzsch heißt der Mann. Der hat damals auf dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin...
Ich gucke mal. Schaut mal unser Chaosradio wiki rein, unter wiki.chaosradio.ccc.de. Da stellen wir gleich mal noch die Links rein, wo wir sie finden. Und dann könnt ihr auch noch mal gucken. Aber da gibt es irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, prozentual... Möglicherweise hat sich das mittlerweile auch geändert.
Es hat sich sicherlich geändert. Aber natürlich sagen die Anbieter, dass sie nicht so viele Karteileichen haben. Denn wenn man für viel Geld verkauft werden würde, also etwa, Studiforz hat ja 50 Millionen an Preis erlangt, von Holzbrinke, genau. Dann will man natürlich nicht gerne zugeben, dass man irgendwie eine Hälfte Karteileichen hat.
Wobei es natürlich gerade bei MySpace ja auch wieder problematisch ist, was den Wert dieser Firma angeht. Und da scheint ein bisschen gerade die Blase zu platzen, dass mal jemand nachfragt, womit macht ihr eigentlich euer Geld? Und das ist ja die große Frage, die wir uns bei den sozialen Netzwerken immer überlegen müssen.
Das heißt, womit machen die eigentlich ihr Geld? Warum haben Leute Interesse, Studio4Z für 50 Mille zu kaufen? Was machen die damit?
Gute Frage. Die Antwort ist natürlich sehr einfach. Wenn man sich die Geschäftsmodelle ansieht, bei MySpace ist das ja noch krasser, denn Robert Murdoch's News Corporation hat 580 Millionen Dollar dafür bezahlt, als sie übernommen wurde. Dann geht es natürlich nicht darum, wie viele Leute kostenlos die Dienste benutzen und dort chatten, sondern es geht natürlich A um die Daten und B natürlich um Werbung. Es gibt auch immer wieder Streit, auch hier in Deutschland, wie Werbung gescheitert werden darf, inwieweit sozusagen die Benutzer, die ihre Profile haben, sich da belästigt fühlen und was noch akzeptabel ist für die Benutzer.
Okay, wir machen mal ganz konkret am Beispiel. Meine MySpace-Seite, Robert Murdoch hat hier gekauft, 580 Millionen Dollar. Der Kranz hat eine MySpace-Seite. Was wird sich da jetzt verändern? Werde ich jetzt Werbung bekommen für Fox News, die ich bitte gucken soll? Und dann sag ich, okay, ist mir egal, guck ich nicht? Oder krieg ich irgendwann...
Die Idee von den Profilen ist schon, dass du dann zielgerichtet Werbung geschaltet kriegen kannst. Das heißt, man wird dann annehmen, wenn du bestimmte Sachen in deinem Profil hast, dass du dann Interesse an bestimmter Werbung hast. Ich weiß nicht, bei MySpace gibt es ja Werbung.
Bei MySpace ist das schon passiert, bei Studi-Vorzeit ist das noch in den Anfängen.
Wobei man sich natürlich auch überlegen muss, wenn die Leute es zu sehr übertreiben mit der Werbung, dann hauen die Leute ab, weil es gibt da quasi kein Alleinstellungsmerkmal. Es gibt zig gleichwertige soziale Netzwerke. Und wenn die Leute mit einem Schlag genervt sind, die ganze Gruppe zieht um, es dauert. Es ist eine langsame Erosion, aber es wird dauern. Es ist halt kein nachhaltiges Geschäftsmodell, was die haben. Es ist einfach eine Blase.
Also zwei Sachen sind natürlich auch interessant an diesem Aspekt. Zum einen, dass es, ich sag mal so, aus der Generation, die nicht mehr im Internet groß geworden ist, immer wieder den Ruf gibt, dass es alles böse und es alles doof, man sollte das abschalten. Ich glaube, das ist meine ganz persönliche Meinung, dass das Quatsch ist, weil es nicht funktionieren wird. Du kannst Dinge, die da sind, nicht mehr wegmachen oder musst dich irgendwie damit arrangieren. Und zum zweiten wird dieses ganze Social Networking-Wahnsinns-Dingens dieses ersten Jahrzehnts vom neuen Jahrtausend wird das in 20 Jahren auch so ein obskures, kleines, merkwürdiges Ding sein, was in Retro-Motto-Shows, wo Leute auf einer Couch sitzen, sich schlechte Musik anhören und dann irgendwie einen Ausdruck von ihrem MySpace-Profil hochhalten und sagen, ich hatte damals auch eins.
Na, das kann man natürlich schwer absehen. Ich denke schon, dass diese sozialen Netzwerke, dazu würden ja auch YouTube, Flickr gehören oder places.com, sicherlich nicht eine Eintagsfliege sein werden. Dafür sind sie einfach in vieler Hinsicht zu praktisch, werden exzessiv genutzt und es ist sicherlich keine Eintagsfliege.
Ich denke, es wird sich weiterentwickeln. Also damals die Mailboxen, die Zeit, mit der wir so groß geworden sind, wo man einfach per Modem, per Telefonhörer sich irgendwo eingewählt hat und dann Textnachrichten ausgetauscht hat, also gar nicht mal Fotos, da war gar nicht dran zu denken. Jetzt haben wir irgendwie die MySpace-Profile mit Fotos und der Lieblingsmusik. Und vielleicht ist es in 20 Jahren soweit, dass wir alle so ein kleines Display vor dem Auge haben, mit so einer Brille, wo man dann die Livestreams von unseren Freunden direkt, ich meine, soweit sind wir gar nicht im Fernsehen, wahrscheinlich keine 20 Jahre vielleicht, sondern nur noch fünf. Und wenn wir darüber so eine Live-Vernetzung haben, dass man also mit einem Augenblick irgendwo die Leute direkt anklickt und direkt einen Livestream zu denen herstellen kann.
Da kann ich ja vielleicht die Geschichte kurz von Gordon Bell erzählen.
Willst du die gleich erzählen? Ich würde nicht erst mal gucken, was Tobi zusammen hat. Hallo Tobi.
Hallo.
Einen wundervollen guten Abend nach Klein Machno.
Oder bei wie vielen Zwergen hast du ein Profil?
Wie viele hast du?
Na, ich bin eigentlich nicht mehr so vielen, weil wenn ich denke, zu viele wär auch nicht schlecht, weil wenn man dann ins Internet ran geht, dann muss man sich erstmal überall anmelden. Das dauert. Und dann kriegt man überall noch diese ganzen E-Mails, diese ganzen Wellen manchmal von E-Mails, die man am Arten kriegt.
Dann verfusselt man sich irgendwann. Dann verfusselt man sich irgendwann.
Ja, und dann muss man allen antworten, was hat der jetzt noch mal geschrieben, was wollte ich jetzt schreiben. Dann macht sowieso auch keinen Spaß mehr. Ich bin jetzt bei Schüler CCC, es geht ja Schüler VZ und Schüler CCC, bei MSN und knuddel zwar ich mal, keine Ahnung.
Was benutzt du da, was am liebsten benutzt, was ist das Feature, was du gerne magst an diesen Netzwerken?
Hauptsächlich nutze ich MSN.
Einfach auch für Chatten normal?
Da ist sowieso, es geht am schnellsten. Muss man enter drücken, dann liest der andere schon. Man kann auch diese ganzen Smilies und diese ganzen bunten Bilder einfach noch mit einfügen und das finde ich auch ganz toll. Bei Schüler CCC ist es mehr so wie Web.de jetzt mal ganz übertragen. Da hast du halt den E-Mail Briefkasten. Man hat ja noch seine ganze Schule und die ganze Klasse. Man kann noch diese ganzen Schuhe von anderen Schulen, die Klassen angucken, wer da alles in der Klasse ist. Also die alle angemeldet sind. Kann die auch als Freundschaft, als Freunde einladen.
Wenn du jetzt mal auf deine eigene Klasse guckst, schätzt man wie viele davon oder weißt du vielleicht sogar, wie viele eben auch einen Account haben, wie du als Kommunikationspartner oder Freund rechnen würdest. Wie viele sind die zu? Und alle auch im selben, sodass sie vom Klassenverband miteinander kommunizieren können? Wie jetzt? Also im selben Netzwerk sind, sodass sie sich unterhalten können.
Na ja, die sind doch auf derselben Seite bei SchülerCC.
Also alle bei SchülerCC und nicht etwa bei MySpace oder Facebook oder so.
Viele sind auch Schülervz, manche meinen CC wäre besser, deswegen lasse ich es auch dabei. Wie gesagt, bei MySpace habt ihr auch vorhin angesprochen, hier so eine Totenkartei und so was, da habe ich mich auch einmal angemeldet. Ich habe meinen Passwort wieder vergessen, mein Name auch wieder.
Du bist also auch eine der Karteileichen.
Ich könnte da gleich eins abziehen von den 100 Millionen.
Nein, das lassen wir schön drin. Wir lassen MySpace mal schön mit diesem großen Sack an Leuten, die sich mal angemeldet haben und eigentlich gar nichts wollen. Die sollen das schön mit sich rumtragen.
Und nun haben wir ja so ein bisschen am Anfang Beispiele gehabt. Na ja, es gibt halt auch so ein paar negative Seiten. Hast du sowas schon mal gehört, dass dir das schon mal passiert?
Eigentlich noch nicht. Also so lange bin ich da noch nicht. Bei den ganzen Sachen da negativ eigentlich noch nicht.
Also um mal ein Beispiel zu konstruieren. SchülerCC, die ganze Schule oder ganze Klasse ist da drin. Und ihr unterhaltet euch und sagt, unser Englischlehrer hat einen totalen Knall und der sportet da rechts bescheuert. So, dann kommt der Englischlehrer, der ist ja auch noch nicht doof. Und klickt sich da auch mit ein, gibt sich auch ein Nickname und liest das alles mit und am nächsten Tag seid ihr Mode. Und es heißt, Freunde, Hefte, Rausklassen, Arbeit. Soweit könnte es ja kommen.
Mein Lehrer ist da glaube ich so angemeldet.
Gibt er sich als Lehrer zu erkennen? Das ist ja spannend.
Also in meiner Klasse gibt es wirklich nur Namen und Gesichter, die ich als Schüler identifizieren kann. Es kann sein, dass in der Parallelklasse oder in der 8. also ich bin neunte, dass vielleicht in der 8. oder in der 10. sich ein Lehrer eingeloggt hat, weiß ich nicht. Also ich habe davon jetzt auch noch nicht gehört. Aber was ich tun würde, wenn es so kommen würde, das wäre irgendwie...
Wäre schon ganz so peinlich, oder? Wenn man da irgendwie sich unbeschwert unterhält und dann plötzlich festgeguckt ist.
Das sowieso, aber der war mir eigentlich auch größtenteils die ganze Klasse betroffen, nicht nur ich alleine.
Ist das denn so, wenn du jetzt mal auf dein eigenes Profil guckst und etwa du so an Bildern drin hast oder so, wäre das für dich okay, wenn du das zum Beispiel in der Elternseele oder Tante, wäre das okay für dich? Also hast du da Sachen drin, die dir ein bisschen unangenehm sind? Oder hast du schon ein bisschen darauf geachtet, dass du halt nicht, naja, keine besoffenen Party-Fotos, weißt du schon?
Na, so lange bin ich noch nicht bei SchülerCC und ich habe sie jetzt auch nur zum Schreiben benutzt, also von daher habe ich auch noch kein Bild drin bei mir, wenn da jemand meinen Namen liest, hat er nur ein dickes Fragezeichen daneben.
Okay, also ist das Zufall oder hast du da eben schon ein bisschen darauf geachtet?
Na, ich hab schon davon gehört, dass wenn man jetzt Bewerbungen abschickt, auch bei sowas mal gucken. Also ich würde jetzt persönlich auch jetzt keine Nacktvotes von mir oder irgendwie was in ihr reinstellen. Ganz normale halt, wo ich rumlaufe oder irgendwo stehe mit Kumpels, das würde ich schon machen, aber...
Aber nichts, was dir nachher irgendwie unangenehm sein könnte?
Wie würdest du damit umgehen, wenn Freunde so Fotos von dir reinstellen? Also jetzt vielleicht keine Nacktfotos, aber vielleicht irgendwie die besoffenen Partyfotos?
Tja, die irgendwie dann vielleicht zwingen sind es nur, wenn es so weit kommen würde, die wieder runterzunehmen.
Also auf jeden Fall bitten zumindest erstmal, also würdest du das nicht gerne wollen?
Nö, oder ich könnte mich hier übrigens drum bitten oder fragen, ob ich das machen könnte. Und wenn das nicht macht, dann soll das halt wieder unternehmen.
Wünschen wir dir sehr, dass es nie so weit kommt, Tobi. Danke dir für den Anruf. Und jetzt brennt der Baum hier, zumindest die Telefonleitung. Der nächste am Telefon ist Owen. Hallo Owen. Von wo rufst du an?
Aus Treptow-Köpenick, also aus Berlin.
Aus Berlin? Du bist quasi im selben Alter wie Tobi gerade und auch vernetzt ohne Ende, oder? Wo denn?
Also es hat bei mir angefangen mit ICQ. Und jetzt bin ich bei MSN, MySpace, Schüler-VZ und Yappi noch.
Tobi sagte ja gerade, das ist ihm schon alles eigentlich viel zu viel, wenn man diese ganzen einzelnen Dinger durchgucken muss und tausend Mails beantworten muss und guckt, wer wo schreibt.
Ja, bei mir ist es so, das MySpace ist wirklich mein Favorit. Also es ist einfach so, dass man bei MySpace sich auch verwirklichen kann. Also bei diesen ganzen anderen ist man ja immer an dieses ganze Schema gebunden. Aber bei MySpace gibt es ja sozusagen die verschiedensten Dinge. Das fängt ja schon an mit diesen ganzen Layouts, die es da gibt. Also dass man die sich zum einen selbst kreieren kann in verschiedensten Farben. Also man hat sozusagen nie was doppelt. Und das finde ich eigentlich schon relativ cool. Also es ist aber halt auch so, dass ich bei vielen bin, weil die eine Gruppe von meinen Freunden ist halt nur da angemeldet. Und die anderen nur da. Aber man will ja trotzdem noch mit ihnen schreiben können.
Also du teilst das so ein bisschen auf. Du bist da bei dem einen bist du so und bei dem anderen bist du so.
Also ich bin jetzt... Veränder mich jetzt.
Du bist schon überall own, aber bei dem einen triffst du die einen Leute und bei dem anderen triffst du die anderen.
Ja genau, also das ist so, dass bei MySpace sind sozusagen eher meine Leute, die sozusagen ein bisschen mehr Grips haben. Weil ich jetzt sage, naja, bei Yappi ist das eher so wirklich so eine Community, wo sich jeder anmelden kann und jeder und jeden anschreiben kann. Und da sind aber halt, ist eben der größte Teil meiner ganzen Klasse oder meines ganzen Freundeskreises. Und deswegen bin ich da eigentlich ja nur angemeldet. Also da bin ich ja seltener online als bei MySpace oder bei MSN.
Was war denn der Ausschlaggebende Grund dich da anzumelden?
Na zum Teil auch der Gruppenzwang glaube ich. Also man hat dann so, bist du da? Nee, dann ist man nach Hause gekommen. Erstmal geguckt, wie es funktioniert und dann angemeldet. Und dann kam man ja vom einen zum nächsten. Und bei Schülerfortzett habe ich mich angemeldet, weil ich war früher in der zweiten Klasse hier in Berlin. Und dann sind wir weggezogen. Und jetzt hat mein Bruder, welches in seiner ehemaligen Klasse wiedergefunden. Und da habe ich mich da jetzt angemeldet, falls mich mal jemand sucht. Und zufällig hat mich heute jemand bei ICQ angeschrieben, den ich aus der zweiten Klasse doch kenne.
Hat dich das gefreut oder eher nicht?
Ja, na doch, weil die Wohnzeit in Rheinland-Pfalz. Aber ich fand es schon lustig, wie wir uns wiedergefunden haben.
Okay, also hat einen echten Nutzwert dann auch für dich. Hast du dich darüber gefreut? Hat dich schon mal jemand angelabert, wo du dich gar nicht gefreut hast?
Das ist eben das Problem bei Yappi, dass ich da diese ganzen Proleten, diese ganzen Chicas und wie sie sich alle heißen, dich dann nur zulabern. Und hier ich komme mit meinen ganzen Freunden. Das nervt halt schon und deswegen gehe ich da nicht so oft online. Ich gehe dann nur zu gucken, wer online ist, ob ich was mit dem machen will und dann schreibe ich den kurz an. Aber ich verbringe da jetzt nicht mehr den ganzen Tag dran.
Okay, dann musst du auch mal noch in der Schule, oder?
Ja, das auch.
Und vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Ja, bitte, bitte.
Soziale Netzwerke im Chaosradio auf Fritz Nummer 134. Hier sind extrem viele Anrufer. Esi, Markus, Paul, bitte ein bisschen Geduld. Wir malen die Nachrichten, danach seid ihr weiter dran. Wir reden über Freuden, Taumel und Kritik dieser ernsten Geschichten. Leute stellen Fotos von euch rein, die ihr eigentlich gar nicht wollt. Personalchefs checken die Profile nach und erfinden plötzlich Dinge, die ihr eigentlich nicht bei eurem Personalchef wissen wollt. Auf der anderen Seite kann man aber auch nicht ohne. Wie geht ihr damit um? Wie lebt ihr in den sozialen Netzwerken 0331 70 97 110? Thema heute im Chaosradio auf fritz.
Outdoor ist in und KenFM auf deiner Seite. Sonntag senden wir live vom Boxi aus Berlin von einem Oldtimer Bus, der zur PA umgebaut wurde. Und die werden wir auch brauchen, denn mit uns sind Spice und die Puppetmasters. KenFM Sonntag vom Boxhagener Platz, vom Dach eines Buses und wem das zu hoch ist, dem sei gesagt, wir erwarten außerdem Gas aus der Schweiz.
Gas, Spice und Puppet-Masters. Beim RWB machen die Sachen schlimm. Ken FM, die Fritz-Radioshow mit Ken Jepsen.
Diesen Sonntag, Sonntag live aus Berlin.
Wir sind vom Dach an des Bootes und der steht auf dem Boxi im Friedrichshain.
Ab 14 Uhr auf allen Frequenzen von Fritz. Und das hört man. Die Bundesregierung stellt mehr Geld zur Verfügung, um den Hunger in der Welt zu bekämpfen. Entwicklungsministerin Vitsorek Zoll sagte dem Ernährungsprogramm der Vereinten Nationen zusätzlich zehn Millionen Euro zu. Nach Ansicht von Bundeskanzlerin Merkel kann der Anstieg der Lebensmittelpreise nur durch ein gemeinsames internationales Vorgehen eingedämmt werden. Deshalb soll sich auch das nächste Gipfeltreffen der acht führenden Industrienationen mit dem Thema befassen. In mehreren Ländern hatte es zuvor gewaltsame Proteste gegeben, weil sich Menschen ihre Grundnahrungsmittel nicht mehr leisten können. BVG-Kunden müssen auch morgen und in den nächsten Tagen mit Ausfällen und Verspätungen rechnen. Weil die Werkstätten bestreikt werden, könnten die Fahrpläne ausgedünnt und Linien verkürzt werden, kündigte BVG-Sprecherin Reetz an. Die U- und Straßenbahnen sollen zwar nach Plan fahren, allerdings sind sie mit weniger Waggons unterwegs. Unterdessen einigten sich heute die BVG und die Gewerkschaft Verdi vor dem Arbeitsgericht Berlin, dass Streiks künftig rechtzeitig angekündigt werden. In der Prignitz sind bei einem Busunfall auf der Autobahn 24 Insassen verletzt worden. Neun Opfer wurden nach Polizeiangaben in umliegende Krankenhäuser eingeliefert, elf Fahrgäste konnten am Unfallort versorgt werden. Der Bus, in dem etwa 60 Jugendliche aus Mecklenburg-Vorpommern saßen, war auf der A24 in der Nähe von Putlitz gegen die Mittelleitplanke geprallt. Der Fahrer hatte nach einem Überholmanöver die Kontrolle über das Fahrzeug verloren. Sport, Basketball, Alba Berlin hat seine Tabellenführung in der Fußball-Bundesliga mit einem Sieg in letzter Sekunde behauptet. Die Berliner gewannen am Abend 74 zu 73, auswärts gegen den Vorjahrestritten Ludwigsburg. Am Abend gibt es nur ein paar Wolken, es bleibt insgesamt trocken und die Temperaturen gehen auf 6 bis 1 Grad runter. Morgen scheint zunächst die Sonne, später ziehen aber ein paar Wolken auf, es soll aber trocken bleiben und die Höchstwerte liegen bei 16 bis 19 Grad. Verkehr mit drei Meldungen. A10, westlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Potsdam. Zwischen Großkreuz und Dreieck Werder besteht Gefahr durch ein defektes Fahrzeug, das dort die rechte Spur blockiert. A12, Berlin, Richtung Frankfurt Oder. Zwischen Storkow und Fürstenwalde West besteht ebenfalls Gefahr, hier durch einen defekten LKW und auch der blockiert die rechte Spur. Und A100, Stadtring, Richtung Neukölln. Im Tunnel im Ortsteil Britz ist die rechte Spur wegen einer Ölspur gesperrt. Wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Die Nachrichten um halb elf mit Alexandra Wann.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz rund um Spremmen.
Chaosradio 134 mit Frank, mit Constanze und mit Jakob. Wir wollen mit euch reden über soziale Netzwerke. Wo seid ihr drin? Was macht ihr da? Und macht ihr euch Sorgen darüber, dass irgendjemand eure Daten weitergibt und ihr da vielleicht einen Job oder was auch immer riskiert? 0331 70 97 110. Aber vorher, bevor es weitergeht, müssen wir natürlich dieses tolle Stück von Pete Green hören, dem kleinen Engländer, der beschlossen hat, dass er kein MySpace hat, weil MySpace fucking sucks. Pete Green heißt der Mann, der Song ist unter der CCC-Lizenz erschienen. Ihr könnt ihn also im Netz ziehen und allen euren Freunden zeigen oder aber, dass wir auch schon ihn einfach aufs MySpace Profil laden. Sehr urkisch. I Haven't Got A MySpace gehört im Chaos Radio auf Fritz am heutigen 23. April. Wir sind eine Woche früher dran als sonst. Ausnahme kommt nicht wieder vor, ansonsten natürlich wie immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Wir haben noch eine neue, eine weitere Nachricht aus der Welt der sozialen Netzwerke und was da alles schiefgehen kann in den letzten Wochen.
Studi4Z freut sich, dass sie endlich die Kiffer-Fotos an die Ermittlungsbehörden geben dürfen. Studi4Z-Geschäftsführer Markus Rieke sagte im Interview mit Spiegel Online, dass er glücklich sei, bei Anfragen nach Fotos die Leute beim Kiffen zeigen, die Nutzerdaten herauszugeben.
Moment, nochmal langsam. Die geben Daten von Leuten an die Ermittlungsbehörden weiter?
Also Hintergrund war, dass sie ihre Geschäftsgebäden-Bedingungen soweit geändert haben oder angepasst haben, dass jetzt den Nutzern auch klar ist, dass sie das auch dürfen oder dass sie das auch tun.
Im Umkehrschluss heißt es dann, ok, wenn du ein Foto von dir so ins Netz stellst, ist das dein Problem, wir werden es weiterleiten.
Genau, also die stehen halt natürlich vor dem Problem, dass sie ganz viele Anfragen kriegen von Ermittlungsbehörden. Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass das so ist. Die sind da ziemlich neugierig. Wir als CCC kennen das von unseren Diensten auch, dass da immer mal wieder Leute anfragen, also gerade bei Anonymisierungsdiensten. Da fragen die Behörden halt an, wir hätten gerne mal die Identität zu Person XY oder zu dem und dem Profil, weil der steht im Verdacht, dass sie das gemacht haben, oder da die und die Bilder reingestellt haben. Dann wollen die gerne die Daten wissen. Die sind natürlich in der Zwickmühle, dass sie einerseits eigentlich nicht so ohne Weiteres die Daten preisgeben wollen, weil dann verlieren sie im Zweifelsfall auch Nutzer und wenn es publik wird, verlieren sie vielleicht auch ein paar Tausend Nutzer dadurch, weil die sagen, die haben hier den und den verpfiffen. Ist natürlich ein Problem für die und jetzt sagen sie, wir haben jetzt einfach klar gemacht allen Nutzern in den Geschäftsbedingungen, wir geben diese Daten raus, wenn entsprechend angefragt wird. Das führt dann zu so einer Schlagzeile, dass sie sagen, okay, vielleicht auch ein bisschen überspitzt formuliert, aber allen Leuten, die da Bilder einstellen, muss klar sein, die können im Zweifelsfall auch irgendwie da landen, wo man sie sich nicht hin wünscht.
Also wir sollten vielleicht, weil wir schon bei den AGB sind, vielleicht noch mal kurz sagen, das ist ja einfach...
AGB sind die allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen, also die Grundlage. Das Kleingedruckte sozusagen. Aber man sollte da reinschauen, die sind auf jeden Fall einen Blick wert.
Da sind einfach auch ein paar ziemlich unangenehme Dinge für die User enthalten. Etwa, dass Studi4Z Strafen bis zu 6000 Euro verhängt, wenn man gegen diese AGBs verstößt. Und es sind so weit wie, dass man etwa versucht, Sicherheitslücken zu finden oder Sicherheitsbarrangieren zu umgehen. Nach den gelungenen Hacks gegen Studi4Z haben sie schlicht in ihre AGB übernommen. Des Weiteren haben sie sich in den AGBs vorbehalten, dass sie nicht haften dafür, wenn unbefugte, die persönlichen, auch die geschützten Profile, die Bilder und die Nachrichten enthalten. Und sie haben obendrauf in ihrer Datenschutzerklärung bestimmt, dass sie natürlich die Instant-Messaging-Nachrichten in bestimmten Fällen einsehen können.
Stellt sich die Frage, ob die Leute, die sich bei, also ob wir alle, wenn wir uns da irgendwo anmelden und wo wir auch immer unterwegs sind, wir wirklich alles gelesen haben, A, B, ob wir es verstanden haben und C, ob wir uns darüber einen Kopf machen. Wir fragen mal Esi aus Uranienburg. Hallo Esi.
Hallo.
Guten Abend. Hast du die AGBs gelesen?
Ja, im Nachhinein.
Also ich hab ganz ehrlich, ich hab kurz drauf geguckt, hab sie gesehen und dachte, oh nee.
Also dazu kommt noch her noch, dass die meistens so in schön hellgrau auf weiß gehalten sind und dann auch nicht gerade lesefreundlich sind.
Also ich muss sagen, so beim Anmelden, die legst du nicht, wer wengt dann irgendwie mal ziemlich lange weiter oder so was, guck sie mir dann doch schon mal an. Wo bist du denn unterwegs? Ja, ich bin bei Yappi, MySpace, MSN, ICQ, also alles.
Hast du da Profile angelegt, wo auch Daten angegeben hast?
Ja, aber ich hab nur Grenzdaten. Also ich hab nicht Daten, die viel über mich aussagen, sondern nur das, was jeder wissen kann.
Also du bist ja schon quasi berufsfähig, also bist ein älter als die vorherigen Anrufer. Bist du auch bei Monster.de oder bei Crossing, bei diesen Plattformen, wo man vielleicht auch irgendwie so Jobs vermitteln kann? Hast du da auch ein Profil?
Nee, da bin ich gar nicht. Ich wusste Monsters, kannte ich aus der Werbung, aber den anderen nicht.
Okay, also was Xing schreibt und die meisten auch Xing aussprechen.
Also ob jetzt Xing oder Crossing ist egal. Easy, was war denn für dich der Anlass, dich da anzumelden?
Ja, Neugierde mehr oder weniger. Aber zum AGB muss ich sagen, die können zwar vieles in die AGBs reinschreiben, was auch schlimm anhört, aber ob sie das dann letztendlich rechtlich durchsetzen können oder ob das rechtlich vertretbar ist, ist eine andere Sache.
Natürlich auch umstritten, vor allen Dingen auch die Frage, die wir jetzt eben angesprochen haben mit den Strafen, dass sie eben zum Beispiel auch Strafen androhen. Wenn Stillschweigen vereinbart wurde, etwa so nach Hackingversuchen, steht das in den AGBs, dass die User darüber schweigen müssen, wenn sie eine Strafe erhalten haben, i.d.sit.
Da würde ich mir lieber die BBGBs und SCGBs durchgucken als die AGBs von denen, denn die sind für mich rechtsbinder als die AGBs, was die da angehen.
Im Zweifelsfall ist das halt aber auch ein ziemlich lästiger Rechtsstreit, den man mit denen hat.
Na ja, kannst du mal sagen, wie viele Freunde hast du in den verschiedenen Plattformen? Also Leute, wie groß sind deine Communities etwa?
Bei MySpace, da ich gerne Band hab und mehr als Bandseite, bin ich dabei schon bei über tausend Freunden.
Was für eine Band? Ich bin sofort neugierig. Was hast du für eine Band?
Ziemlich weitläufig. Einen kategorisieren will ich mich gar nicht, weil wir eigentlich mehr oder weniger alles von Balladen bis schnellen Hardrock-Rock spielen.
Also ihr macht keinen Hip-Hop und ihr macht keinen Elektro, ihr macht Rockmusik im weitesten Sinne.
Alles, was noch ein bisschen können erfordert.
Okay, aber 1000 Freunde ist natürlich viel.
Bei Myspace ist immer das Problem, du wirst dir edit und du kennst die gar nicht. Dadurch kommen die meisten Freunde. Und wenn es Bands sind, dann nehme ich gerne an, weil man so ein bisschen andere Bands kennenlernt und schreibt man sich auch. Allerdings, wenn es dann welche einzelnen User sind, die man nicht mal kennt, weil die einen nicht mal geschrieben haben, dann wird es meistens abgelenkt, wozu. Nur, dass sie dann in einer Liste stehen, das ist schön. Da habe ich auch nichts mitgewonnen.
Was würdest du machen, wenn von einem Tag auf den anderen diese Dinge abgeschaltet werden? Bricht die Welt zusammen?
Nein, zusammenbrechen nicht. Allerdings wird es schon eine Einschränkung im Freizeitleben. Da muss man sich an andere Hobbys suchen.
Organisierst du deine Freizeit auch darüber?
Nein, gar nicht. Also Freunde über Handy anrufen, hab da Lust, wollen wir da hingehen, aber kaum über diese Community.
Sagen wir mal zu deinem Profil zurück. Du stellst ja nur Daten rein, die andere auch sehen können. Was hast du da so in deinem Profil drin?
Sag doch mal, wie die Band heißt. Ich guck mal schnell. Wir sollten mal fragen, ob er das möchte. Können wir jetzt sagen, wenn Easy seine Daten ins Netz stellt, dann sind die ja öffentlich.
Wie heißt deine Band?
Absolut heißen wir, allerdings war es schon besetzt. Da musste ich Band absolut, aber ich weiß ja nicht, wie man das über MySpace erreicht. Also ich weiß, dass ich das reinkriege, da ich mich ja anmelde, aber wie man das von außen erreicht, keine Ahnung. Aber wir haben auch eine Internetseite, wo wir auch einzeln.
Aber du hast dann ein Foto von dir drin, eine Name, Geburtsdatum?
Genau, Geburtsdatum, Name, Hobbys, was ich mache, halt das, was andere wissen dürfen. Inoffizielle Sachen werde ich ganz bestimmt nicht reinstellen, die andere nicht wissen brauchen unbedingt.
Kannst du das nachvollziehen, dass andere Leute sowas reinstellen? Oder ist das für dich völlig absurd, dass da Leute irgendwie ihre halbnackt Fotos, Dessous-Aufnahmen reinstellen, irgendwelche sexuellen Vorlieben?
Ich sag mal so, es ist selbst überlassen, wie weit er sich öffentlich präsentiert oder nicht. Dann kann er in Neuseit auch nackt über einen Alex rennen. Dann sind auch Tausende von Leuten, wie er aussieht.
Ich hab heute im Laufe des Tages noch eine ganz lustige Mail bekommen. Das ist ein Fall, wo eine BDSM-Gruppe bei StudiVZ, die da ihre Community hatten, ihre Gruppe, die sich darüber beschwert hatten, dass sie gelöscht worden ist. Das finde ich schon sehr mutig, mit so ein bisschen ausgefallenen Sexualleben da so eine Gruppe zu haben bei StudiVZ.
Also ich meine mal, wo man nur ab über 18 mit Ausweisbescheinigung, dann meinetwegen können sie 3-Jährige nicht, weil ab 18 ist eh kann man. Aber alles, wo auch Minderjährige rein können und sich die Fotos angucken können ohne Probleme, finde ich, da wird sowas nicht rein.
Ich hätte jetzt eher die Sorge, dass das noch wirklich öffentlich wird. Bei so einer Gruppe, das ist ja nicht wirklich eine private Sache. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie offen die Leute, die in dieser Gruppe waren, das auch leben. Aber ich persönlich hätte da irgendwie ein schlechtes Gefühl.
Das kommt doch immer auf die Menschen an. Manche sind so, manche haben da ein kleines Charme-Fühl, manche haben überhaupt kein Charme-Fühl und das ist gleich voller Breitseite. Also das ist immer von den Menschen abhängig, oder? Die hinter dem Profil stehen.
Das ist sehr, sehr richtig formuliert. Easy, ich finde immer noch deine Band nicht. Band absolut, keine Ahnung.
Ja, also muss ich mal gucken. Ich kann mir mal eine E-Mail schreiben.
Schick mir eine Mail wieder, wie die heißen. Gucken wir mal drauf.
Ist das unter dem die E-Mail-Adresse? Ich bin jetzt gerade nicht zu Hause.
Pass mal auf, bleib mal kurz dran. Die Kollegin wird dir noch eine E-Mail-Adresse geben, wa? Alles klar. Danke dir für den Anruf. Nächste, machen wir gleich weiter, ist Markus. Hallo Markus. Guten Abend. Easy hat dir gesagt, AGBs lesen, naja, müsste man eigentlich irgendwann später, wenn man mal Zeit hat. Wie ist denn es mit dir?
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, so viel lange Weile werde ich nie haben. Weil, nee, oh mein Gott, also, nee, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Wo bist du denn so unterwegs?
Na, ich bin bei MySpace an Studio 4Z angemeldet, allerdings bin ich da vielleicht, wenn es hochkommt, einmal am Tag, eine halbe Stunde online.
Also nicht schwerstabhängig, sondern nur so moderat.
Nee, das nicht. Allerdings hat sich, also, Icq und MSN ist da eher mein Schwerpunkt, sagen wir's mal so. Ich meine, ich bin auch nicht jeden Tag online und auch nicht, wenn dann am Wochenende klar, mal länger, je nachdem, wie es mit Arbeit und so was aussieht. Aber, ja, also, ich hab so, ich glaub, in beiden Listen so um die 500 Leute drinne. Ja, also ich sag mal, es überschneidet sich halt auch, dadurch, dass der eine Mal nur ein ISQ drinne ist, oder nur ein MSN, hat man halt beides. Aber ich sag mal, die Hälfte ist in beiden drinne, und die andere Hälfte ist halt so irgendwo geteilt, sagen wir's mal so.
Ich kann ja mal dir zum Vergleich so einen statistischen Wert sagen, wo mal so Daten ausgewertet wurden. Statistisch hat der User 40 bis 45 Freunde. Also, da bist du wohl weit drüber, liegt natürlich daran.
Da sind vielleicht auch die Karteileichen bei, oder?
Ja, genau, da sind die Karteileichen bei. Ist schon klar.
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Also eigentlich, ich mein, gut, mit jedem schreibt man sich natürlich nur nicht jeden Tag, aber naja, so im Monat würde ich dann eigentlich schon sagen, dass ich mit eigentlich jedem dann mindestens ein bis zehnmal geschattet hab. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich, ich mein klar, ich hab auch welche drinnen, mit denen ich nicht schreibe, beziehungsweise Leute, die mir dann irgendwann wirklich auf den Sack gegangen sind, wo ich dann gesagt hab, gut, okay, bei MSN muss ich sie dann löschen, beziehungsweise hab ich die Visible Liste noch nicht gefunden, sagen wir's mal so. Hab auch nicht wirklich Bock, das zu suchen, aber bei SQ schmeißt die einfach in die Ignor-Liste rein oder in die Visible Liste, so dass ich dann halt unsichtbar bin und dann können die mich, ich sag mal, auch hintenrum heben. Also da gibt's dann aber nicht so viele und nach einer Zeit probiert man das halt mal wieder, dann kommen die da wieder raus, weil sie sich dann eingekriegt haben wieder so ein bisschen oder man selbst so die Einstellung mal wieder so ein bisschen verändert hat oder wie man das auch immer ausdrücken darf jetzt.
Also du nutzt es jetzt, um es zusammenzufassen, hauptsächlich um so soziales Netzwerk zu verbinden, um dich mit Leuten zu unterhalten, mit Leuten zu treffen. Oder mal zu gucken, was gerade Leute treiben, die du lange nicht gesehen hast. Du hast ja vor allen Dingen Datenschützer beim Thema soziale Netzwerke und Leute stellen irgendwie Profile von sich und Fotos und so ins Netz. Die kriegen ja da verschreckt geweitete Augen und einen dicken Hals, weil sie sagen zu Recht auch, auf der einen Seite haben die Leute Angst, dass irgendwie der Staat in oder irgendjemand da in ihr privates Leben reinguckt. Auf der anderen Seite nageln sie ihr gesamtes Leben draußen sichtbar für alle ans Fenster. Wie gehst denn du damit um?
Ja, also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich mach das nicht. Ich hab in ICQ und MSN auch nicht mal meine Adresse oder sowas eingegeben, weil ich sag mal, wenn mir irgendjemand sympathisch ist, wo ich dann möchte oder würde wollen, dass der die Adresse bekommt im Sinne von komm doch mal her oder sowas, wir treffen uns mal oder so. Was ich bisher eigentlich bis jetzt auch noch nicht so gemacht hab direkt, sondern dann eher wirklich in Berlin getroffen oder so erstmal irgendwo getroffen und nicht damit der gleich wusste, da wohnst du und so sieht deine Bude aus und sowas, sondern wirklich erstmal den privat oder persönlich dann abgecheckt hat und dann da irgendwo mitbekommen hat, ist er vielleicht doch anders oder die als man sich die Person vorgestellt hat oder ist es wirklich so. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, wer da seine ganzen Daten reinstellt, soll es machen, soll sich andersrum aber auch nicht wundern, wenn es dann ein Schuss in den Ofen war, also nach hinten in irgendeiner Hinsicht losgeht.
Hast du das schon mal so etwas erlebt?
Also ich persönlich nicht, aufgrund dessen, dass ich das ja nicht mache.
Aber so im Umfeld, wenn du sagst, du hast da 500 Leute um dich herum?
Ja, natürlich.
Findest du dann manchmal unter diesen Leuten Profile, wo du sagst, ach du meine Güte, haben die dir gerne Waffel?
Ja, also was man ja bei Studio4Z öfters sieht, also wie kann man wirklich die Bilder reinstellen, wo man auf einer Party war und dann irgendjemand fotografiert hat, wo man sich die Kante gegeben hat und dann hinterm Busch musste, weil es nicht mehr drin bleiben wollte. Ich weiß nicht, wie kann man die Bilder reinstellen. Das ist irgendwas, was ich nicht verstehen kann, weil sich das dann wirklich jeder angucken kann, wenn er es dann will. Ich persönlich würde es nicht wollen, da irgendwelche fremden Menschen seine Körperflüssigkeiten wieder auscheinen zu sehen.
Also das heißt, du hast schon so ein bisschen Sensibilität dafür. Du wirst also jetzt nicht die Piepshow von dir selbst machen. Aber das würde ich jetzt für dich auch kein Grund sein, komplett zu lassen, weil du einfach auch viele Funktionen praktisch findest.
Verstehe. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, Internet komplett weg. Oder halt auch diese Chat-Rume oder sowas. Ich meine, ich habe jetzt mein Internet auch erst seit einem Jahr. Davorher bin ich immer mit Notebook so gut wie jeden Tag zum Kumpel. Und dann ging das auch, war natürlich mal ein bisschen umständlich, aber dadurch, dass man sich sowieso mal getroffen hat, ging das auch so. Und seitdem ich selbst Internet hab, also bei dem ich da immer war, ich hab das nie verstanden, wie der sagen könnte, wenn der gesagt hat, ohne Internet wäre überhaupt nicht gut, da würde ich ja eine Krise kriegen und sowas, konnte ich bis ich Internet hatte überhaupt nicht verstehen. Aber das hat keine Woche gedauert.
Und jetzt haben sie dich auch dran.
Ich meine, klar, irgendwo ist es eine Sucht. Aber es gibt auch Wichtiges, das ist mir auch klar. Ja, ich sag mal, die eine oder andere Person, die schweift dann wirklich nur noch im Internet rum und vernachlässigt die persönlichen sozialen Kontakte komplett. So ist bei mir nicht so. Demnach, ich meine, ich bin zwar auch ziemlich viel im Internet, auch was das Spielen und sowas angeht, worüber man oder ich zumindest auch ziemlich viele Leute kennenlerne, wodurch das dann halt alles so zustande gekommen ist.
Pass mal auf, ich möchte jetzt noch zum Schluss eine These weiter in den Raum stellen, die wir dann vielleicht auch noch weiter diskutieren können. Dadurch, dass man sein soziales Netzwerk mittlerweile online sortiert und da Leute trifft, sind eigentlich die Handy-Rechnungen kleiner geworden? Das wär immer auch mal spannend. Und da haben die Mobilfunkanbieter das schon mitgekriegt und geben das, werfen das Ding mit Flatrate um sich, weil ja sonst keiner mehr telefonieren würde. 0331 77 97 110, Blue Moon, Chaos Radio auf Fritz, Nummer 134, wir reden über soziale Netzwerke. Danke dir, Markus.
Ja und vor allem würden uns mal Anrufe interessieren, die auch mal ein richtig fettes Profil haben. Wir wollen jetzt mal so ein Profil sehen.
Glauben sind die denn, die man immer so findet?
Genau, sind alle so vorsichtig und alle stellen nix rein, aber dann würden diese sozialen Netzwerke ja gar nicht funktionieren. Das wär ja total langweilig, wenn da niemand was von sich reinstellt, dann...
Man muss doch auch jemanden finden und da tut man über die Profile.
Also wir wollen jetzt hier mal ein richtig fettes Profil sehen.
Ja, ich hab natürlich so eine Daten schon ausgewertet. Natürlich findet man ne Menge. Aber offenbar rufen diese Leute hier nicht an. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen unangenehm, wenn man das fette Profil hat und sein Leben blockt oder eben sehr viele Fotos von sich drin hat.
Aber du machst das ja auch bewusst. Also du stellst ja auch bewusst deine Fotos da rein und blockst.
Da sind übrigens gerade 17 Gigabyte Fotos, eine Fotosammlung, ich glaube von MySpace? MySpace, genau. 17 Gigabyte, das ist echt richtig viel. Das sind...
Auch die geschützten Profile?
Drei, vier DVDs voll Daten ungefähr, voll Fotos. Und ein Bekannter von mir hat da mal so durchgeklickt und meint, boah, es ist langweilig. Also so richtig die bekannten Fotos waren da jetzt nicht bei. Vielleicht sind die schon vorher alle aussortiert worden. Aber vielleicht ist es auch alles gar nicht so schlimm mit diesen Horror-Geschichten, wie wir sie jetzt hier so schon gehört haben.
Wird da nur Panik gemacht, das ist alles ganz undramatisch.
Wär mal interessant. Also ruft an, wenn ihr mal ein richtig fettes Profil habt mit tollen Party-Fotos drin und ihr seid die Hechte.
0331797160 Wir hören jetzt ein weiteres nettes Stück über das Internet von einem Typ namens Tom Millsam, Engländer, der ein Liebeslied 2.0 geschrieben hat. The Internet lovesong.
Ich bin dereste, der dich hier sieht.
Das ist der Internet-Lachsang von Tom Mirsom im Chaosradio auf Fritz Nummer 134. Hallo Paul. Hallo. Schönen guten Abend. Von wo rufst du an? Wir sind bei sozialen Netzwerken, Online-Communities. Nennen sie wie du willst. Bist du da unterwegs?
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Also ich bin so...
Warum rufst du denn an?
Weil ich da angemeldet bin.
Achso, du bist eine Kartei-Leiche.
Könnte man eigentlich so sagen. Also ich bin bei Animax angemeldet. Das ist so ein Anime-Foom, also für Fans von Animis und Mangas. Da organisiert man auch jede Woche mehrere Treffen. Und da kann man dann sich ja mal treffen.
Im realen Leben oder virtuell?
Im realen Leben. Also man verabredet sich da und dann steht auch der Standpunkt fest. Und das organisieren dann auch manchmal Fans. Dann gibt es dann auch Kostüm-Festivals. Und dann gibt es auch mal pro Jahr eine ganz große Veranstaltung. Ja, und dann kann man dann Freunde sehen, die man vielleicht lange nicht sieht.
Das ist aber schon so sehr speziell fachbezogen oder jetzt themenbezogen. Also wir haben ja auch überlegt, was trennt eigentlich oder wo unterscheidet man jetzt ein soziales Netzwerk von so einem klassischen Internetforum, wo man sich irgendwie über DSL-Anschlüsse unterhält.
Oder luftgekühlte VW-Käfermotoren oder so.
Und eigentlich so unsere übereinstimmende Definition war eigentlich, dass alles das, wo es irgendwie über dieses Thema hinausgeht. Also vielleicht wirklich private Kontakte knüpfen, Party verabreden, gemeinsame Interessen finden. Also andere über diese eine Sache hinausgeht.
Das kann man auch machen. Da gibt es auch ein Chat-Forum. Und da kann man sich extra mit welchen dann schreiben. Und dann kann man natürlich auch noch was darüber hinaus machen. Also es ist nicht so, dass alle, die da sind, nur über Animes sind.
Ja, das ist schon klar. Aber das ist ein Forum. Ob das jetzt ein Anime-Forum ist oder was auch immer, ist natürlich ein bisschen anders als ein myfacespeakingvzbook.com.
Hast du da auch ein Profil eigentlich? Hast du in dem Forum auch ein Profil?
Jetzt bei Animax? Ja, ich hab mich da angemeldet. Aber erst seit letzter Woche, Samstag oder so. Und deswegen konnte ich ja noch nicht so viel machen. Ich wollte nur gucken, welchen Treffen ich da jetzt hingehen kann. Aber die konnte man auch so einsehen, wenn man sich mal nicht angemeldet hat. Bloß weil ich jetzt bei so einem Cosplay, also so einem Kostümwettbewerb in der Jury mit sein will, muss ich mich da anmelden.
Ah, Orla von Herdendruck.
Wir haben gelernt, wenn wir was über Animes wissen wollen, dann gucken wir bei Animax rein.
Ganz interessant, die Werbetreibenden, die so in diesen ganzen Studi, VZ und wie sie alle heißen, Werbung schalten, die haben erkannt, dass der Trend eher zu diesen sehr speziellen Communities und fachbezogenen Gruppen, Foren, wie auch immer hingeht.
Weil es sonst zu sehr ausufert und beliebig wird.
Ja, die Dinger sind einfach beliebig und diese Fachforen, da kann man natürlich auch viel zielgerichtete Werbung machen, weil ich weiß, wenn ich jetzt im Animeforum bin, dann kann ich da ziemlich zielgerichtet Werbung machen und das klappt viel, viel besser, als wenn ich einfach die Werbung so breit streuen muss.
Wir machen ja keine Werbung, wir machen ja nur zielgerichtet um eine Zeitansage. Es ist 23 Uhr. Auf der einen Seite nutzen wir soziale Netzwerke, um zu arbeiten, um zu schnattern, Fotos zu tauschen, Termine zu verabreden, uns mit Gleichgesinnten zu treffen. Auf der anderen Seite werden unsere Profile von Leuten, die Interesse daran haben, durchgesucht und wir haben dann möglicherweise später Ärger mit dem Personalchef oder mit der Frau oder dem Partner oder wem auch immer, mit dem Prof an der Uni, weil die auf unseren Profilen Dinge gesehen haben, die wir besser nicht ins Netz gestellt haben. Darüber reden wir heute mit euch. 0331 70 97 110, Constanze ist hier, Frank ist hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir haben noch eine Stunde Zeit. Schnattert mit uns über eure sozialen Netzwerke. Warum seid ihr da drin? Was ist das Besondere daran? Und habt ihr schon mal ein bisschen so im Hinterkopf diesen Gedanken gehabt. Was wäre, wenn das jetzt Leute in die Finger kriegen, die das eigentlich gar nicht sehen sollen? Hallo Matthias. Servus eigentlich, oder?
Na ja, in Stuttgart sagt man nicht unbedingt Servus.
Da kommt jetzt wieder der arrogante Berliner durch, der sagt, alles was südlich von Potsdam ist, ist Servus. Nein, das ist natürlich Unsinn. Hallo Matthias, grüß dich.
Ich hab irgendwann mal gehört, wie ihr versucht habt, Schäwisch zu schwätzen und das war sehr peinlich.
Das kann man, das ist doch Unsinn. Nein, das macht man ja auch nicht.
Das können wir doch gar nicht.
Okay, deine Meinung zu Social Networks?
Ja genau, also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie ihr am Anfang das definiert habt. Also ob jetzt ICQ, MSN und solche Sprays, ob ihr das dazuzählt. Also ich würde es eigentlich nicht dazuzählen, weil so etwas wie ICQ ist jetzt halt einfach so ein Nachrichtendienst halt für mich zum Chatten.
Und du haust nicht irgendwie deine Fotos, deine Interessen, dein Zeug da mit rein?
Meine Profile bei den Diensten sind alle komplett leer. Also ich hatte neulich auch einen Kumpel von mir, hab ich den halt plötzlich gesehen, der war online, der ist nur ganz nett, und dann hab ich geschrieben, hey hallo, wie geht's denn so?
Und der so, ja, wer bist denn du?
Weil aus deinem Profil geht gar nichts vor. Und dann ging es von mir hin und her, ja ich bin der und der. Aber wo ich halt inzwischen raus bin, ist halt Studi4Z. Ich war halt als einziges im Studi4Z, beziehungsweise ich wurde dazu gezwungen.
Wie gezwungen? Hat irgendjemand gesagt, wenn du dich jetzt da nicht anmeldest, dann werf ich deine Socken aus dem Fenster?
Also es hat halt wirklich schon so angefangen, wie du bist nicht im Studi4Z, wie kann ich denn da mit dir kommunizieren? Ja, genau, das Hinstellen der Serie ist völlig unmöglich ohne das. Und dann, also es war halt dann so, da saß ich mit einem Kumpel irgendwie im Internetcafé und dann so, jetzt komm, ich müsste dich jetzt auch mal bei Studi4Z anmelden. Da sag ich mir die ganze Zeit, nee, ich denk gar nicht dran, will ich nicht. Hat er gesagt, okay, das mach ich jetzt einfach mal für dich. Meine E-Mail-Adresse hatte er, meinen Namen kannte er sowieso. Da musste man das Geburtsdatum angeben, hat er gesagt, wie ist mein Geburtsdatum? Sag ich dir, das sag ich dir doch jetzt nicht. Hat der bei icq.com nach mir gesucht und mein Geburtsdatum rausgefunden. Und hat dann halt eben mein Profil da angelegt. Dann kam natürlich so eine E-Mail von wegen, ja, klicken Sie jetzt hier und innerhalb von 10 Tagen, und wenn man das dann nicht macht, dann wird's wieder gelöscht. Hab ich halt erstmal ignoriert. Um es dann nur ein paar Monate später musste ich mich dann wieder nochmal von Hand angemeldet, weil wie, du bist ja immer noch nicht da drin und ich kann ja immer noch nicht mit dir reden. Und dann war es halt so, ich hab mich wieder angemeldet und dann war das fertig, ich hab mich wieder freigeschaltet und dann hatte ich sofort einen Freund. Nämlich denjenigen und da hab ich mich gefragt, Moment mal, wie geht denn das jetzt? Entweder, ich hab halt meinen Kumpel gefragt, wieso bist du jetzt schon so mein Freund? Ja, damals hab ich ihn doch gleich schon hinzugefügt. Dann hab ich mich gesagt, Moment mal, wenn Sie behaupten, Sie hätten meinen Account nach den 10 Tagen oder wie viel das ist, ist ohne Bestätigung gelöscht, wieso habe ich dann immer noch einen Freund? Komisch, ja, also vielleicht ist einfach nur die Datenbank da schlecht organisiert.
Oder Sie mögen nicht so gern Accounts löschen, weil Daten sind ja auch Geld wert.
Ja, richtig.
Also nicht die Daten, sondern die Zahl.
Genau, und also inzwischen bin ich halt raus aus dem Studio 4Z, also richtig den Auslöser. Also ich war erst schon verärgert über diese neuen AGBs, die wir halt da gemacht haben. Die fand ich schon einfach nicht so toll, bin aber noch so ein bisschen drin geblieben. Und dann der Auslöser, das ich rausgebe, halt dann das, was sie vorhin auch schon zitiert hat, mit diesen Kiffer-Bildern, das war es beispielsweise online. Da habe ich mir gedacht, nee Leute, das kann doch gar nicht sein. Einst schon dieser Tonfaktor, es ist ja so schön, dass wir das jetzt endlich können und so. Also ich habe jetzt keine Kiffer-Bilder und auch so irgendwie die betrunkenen Tati-Fotos halten sich irgendwie auch in Grenzen. Aber wenn, also ich habe sowieso selber auch gar keine reingestellt, das finde ich auch so schlimm. Dann stellen andere Fotos rein und können einen darauf verlinken. Am besten gleich noch auf dem Gesicht und dann steht da, ja dieser Mensch ist auf so und so Fotos verlinkt. Naja und dann war halt so das Prozedere, bis man auf Studio4Z erstmal raus ist. Dann gibt man hier in der Einstellung ja Account löschen und dann kommt noch die Rückfrage, ja bist du jetzt wirklich sicher und dann kommt noch mal, ja überleg doch mal, weil wenn mir die Freunde und die Frage, wissen wir doch gar nicht so schlimm und wir geben auch gar nichts raus, dann muss man noch mal bestätigen und dann noch mal eine E-Mail. Also irgendwann war man da mal raus, aber man hat ziemlich viel Arbeit, bis sie einen endlich mal da rauslassen und dann noch so was anderes, von wegen, dass der Personalchef da reinguckt, ich, ein Freund von mir arbeitet bei Porsche.
Wie alle anderen in Stuttgart auch wahrscheinlich, der lässt es dann bei dem anderen aus dem Autobau.
Nee und da war es halt so irgendwie, der ist halt in so einer Filiale tätig und dann hieß es, kam irgendwie eine Trafikantin zum Forschungsgespräch und danach kam dann halt der Chef zu meinem Freund so, ja das war ja so ganz nett und jetzt gucken sie doch mal in dieses komische Studie-VZ rein, da sind sie ja auch angemeldet, ob wir die auch wirklich annehmen können. Und da haben sie halt Texte über sich gefunden und dann hat sie an ihre Stelle auch bekommen. Ja aber einfach, dass da halt so nachgeschaut wird und ich finde das irgendwie pervers. Ja also gut, man möchte so als Arbeitgeber vielleicht wissen, wer das für ein Mensch so ist, ja, aber dann da so sich dafür zu interessieren, ob es da zu viele besoffene Party-Fotos gibt oder irgendetwas in der Richtung. Ich meine, das interessiert den doch gar nicht zu interessieren, ja. Also so lange ich morgens pünktlich auf der Matte stehe und mich konzentriert da arbeiten kann, hat mein Arbeitgeber doch mein Privatleben eigentlich in Scheißdreck zu interessieren. Und das nächste ist ja, die Chefs haben ja früher bestimmt auch nicht, haben auch großartig Partys gemacht, haben davon halt keine Fotos in der Internet gestellt. Es wird ja so hingestellt, als wenn jemand sich mal besäuft, oder so, dass der dann gleich ein Unmensch ist, den man dann nicht mehr einstellen kann.
Also ist das eigentlich ein legitimes Mittel, ich hab ja von Arbeitsrechten so wirklich viel Ahnung, aber dass der Personalchef da reingucken kann, beziehungsweise der Personalchef nicht mal selber, sondern irgendjemand anders sagen kann, hier gucken sie doch mal an dieses Studi-Dingsbums und recherchieren sie doch mal alles über diese Person.
Das haben die Leute öffentlich gemacht, also vom rein Rechlichen her. Es gibt da nichts einzuwenden gegen, müssen halt die Leute sich selbst überlegen. Wir haben da übrigens auch, wir hatten diesen Punkt auch, wir haben ja so ein paar Sachen mal uns schon vorher so Nachrichten quasi gemacht dazu, so eine Kurz-Nachrichten. Und da ist diese Geschichte mit diesem Personalchef, den natürlich einmal, dass die Profile bei Google sind, aber eben auch, dass mittlerweile in diesem Netzwerk nachgeschaut wird.
Also mir ist neulich, vielleicht kann ich jetzt bei der Gelegenheit erzählen, mir ist neulich tatsächlich mal so ein Fall passiert, wo sich eine Studentin beworben hat und sie hatte in ihrem Blog sehr offen darüber geschrieben, dass sie schwanger ist. Tja, das war natürlich unangenehm, weil sie hatte beim Bewerbungsgeschäft belogen, was du tun darfst. Das war natürlich eher unangenehm für sie.
Der Careerkiller Social Network wird in den nächsten Jahren das weitaus größere Problem gegenüber dem Careerkiller Google werden. Mittlerweile ist auch bei den hinterletzten Personalverantwortlichen in den Firmen angekommen, dass man bei Bewerbungen nicht nur Google anwirft, sondern auch mal die üblichen Social Networks durchsieht. Dabei sind es oft nicht die eigenen Sauv-Party-Fotos, die zum Verhängnis werden, sondern die von Kumpels eingestellten und dann verlinkten.
Haben wir ganz genauso von dir gehört. Es ist gut, dass du das noch mal bestätigst.
Ja, und ich finde es auch so ein bisschen so, man kann ja gegen diese Verlängerung auch irgendwie so nicht wirklich was tun. Ich habe auch so das Gefühl, es gibt ja schon die Funktion von wegen Link entfernen oder Protest anmelden oder so. Aber ich habe auch so das Gefühl, dass man da steht, kann ich das jetzt irgendwie meinem Freund zumuten, dass ich ihm hingehe und ihm quasi auf diesen Umweg sage, von wegen, das Foto hätte ich jetzt gerne nicht.
Naja, aber dein Freund hat es auch reingestellt.
Er hätte dich fragen können. Genau.
Also nicht nur fragen können, hätte er es auf möglichen Fall müssen.
Es ist einfach so dieser Drang. Es ist alles so einfach. Und selbst der schlimmste Dau kann damit so ein paar Klicks alles Mögliche reinstellen und weiß vielleicht gar nicht, was er da wirklich tut.
Würdest du jetzt deinen Freunden abberaten, so ein Netzwerk zu nutzen und da auch sich zu präsentieren?
Also im Prinzip würde ich da auf jeden Fall schon immer abraten. Das Einzige, für was es halt gut ist, ist, mit Leuten wirklich in Kontakt zu kommen, von denen man irgendwie gerade überhaupt keine Daten mehr hat und die man irgendwann mal irgendwo getroffen hat.
Aber dazu musst du ja erstmal Daten reinstellen, ne?
Richtig, genau. Und das finde ich das Problem. Ich habe einfach keine Lust auf diese ganzen Spielchen. Wobei ich jetzt allerdings schon wieder die Befürchtung hege, ich fange jetzt im Herbst an zu studieren, dass ich dann wieder genötigt werde von wegen wie, du hast keins und dann kann ich ja gar nicht mit dir. Aber mein Plan, falls dann die Nötigung zu schlimm wird, ist halt so ein Fake-Profil reinzustellen, was ja dann nach den neuen AGBs bei StudiVZ auch ganz groß war.
Na, das würde er dann gegen die AGB verstoßen.
Ja, aber na gut, wenn da Leute drin sind, die heißen Mima Mulliland oder so, die sind immer noch drin und...
Kostet ja eine Strafe von 6000 Euro, wenn sie dich damit kriegen.
Das wusste ich jetzt zum Beispiel auch noch gar nicht.
Ich muss mich mit meinem Klarnamen anmelden.
Das ist ganz interessant, dass man, weil das Telemediengesetz sieht nämlich ausdrücklich vor, dass man auch Dienste Pseudonym nutzen kann. Es wäre mal interessant, ob das nicht sogar im Widerspruch steht.
Ja, dass die AGB rechtmäßig sind, ist ja von vielen Seiten bestritten worden. Also es ging ja auch, denke ich, viel durch die Blogs. Also ich glaube, da hat sich Studiforz ja doch ein echtes Eigentor geschossen. Die haben eigentlich seit Anbeginn eine unglaublich schlechte Presse. Die tun aber auch das Beste dafür.
Die haben sich sehr amateurhaft. Da gibts so einige Possen.
Matthias, danke dir für deinen Anruf. Sehr gerne. Und der nächste am Telefon ist Benedikt aus Düsseldorf. Hallo nach Düsseldorf.
Morgen.
Moin, wie spät ist denn bei dir schon? Wo bist du unterwegs?
Leider nur, also zum Glück nur im Studiforz. Weil, wie soll man sagen, meine Meinung nach ist das im Endeffekt, benutzt man Studiforz nur deswegen, weil die Leute zu dumm sind, irgendwie sich eine eigene Seite zu schreiben, um die Bilder da drauf zu stellen.
Ah, also quasi der Ersatz für eine eigene Homepage.
Genau, man macht einfach Fotos und bis man die dann mal irgendwie per TD rumgibt, das dauert viel zu lange oder funktioniert eh nicht. Und einen FDP zu betreiben ist auch viel zu kompliziert.
Ich kenne das von MySpace, dass auch viele Leute, die irgendwie eine MySpace-Seite haben, die einfach zu faul sind, eine eigene Homepage zu machen. Das Problem ist, dass man von diesen MySpace-Seiten echt Augenkrebs kriegt. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie so gewollt ist von denen, ob das gar nicht anders geht.
Naja, und ist das eine Sicherheitslöcke. Also dadurch, dass so viele Möglichkeiten dem MySpace-Seite gegeben wird, haben sich natürlich auch wieder Leute gefunden, die das ausnutzen. Da gab es diese berühmte Seite, wo jemand Microsoft-Updates anbote. Das waren dann, also bei Trojaner war das eine gehackte Seite. Das ist natürlich auch wieder umstritten.
Es gibt ja dann auch so diese netten Pixel-Seiten, das ist ja im Endeffekt genau dasselbe, dass man halt einfach so dann in diese Richtung geht.
Aber jetzt, unabhängig davon, dass das quasi Internetseite oder eigene Homepage für Idioten ist, der Vorgang bleibt doch derselbe. Ich stelle Dinge aus meinem Leben online, also sei es Fotos aus dem Urlaub oder von irgendeiner Familienfete oder von meinen Leuten aus der Klasse oder was auch immer. Und die stehen dann da im Netz und irgendjemand anders kann, ohne dass ich das eigentlich möchte, über mich Informationen sammeln.
Ja, aber es ist ein Unterschied, ob ich jetzt im Endeffekt in ein Social Network einsetze oder einfach nur auf einem FDP, wo man dann noch Benutzerdaten verbraucht. Oder Passwortschützen. Die ich die Person dann im Endeffekt nur geben kann.
Also du denkst schon, dass es damit zu tun ist, dass es für normale User einfach zu benutzen ist? Ja, also die Sauheit des Menschen. Ich denke auch, das kann man glaube ich auch gerade bei so sehr jungen Leuten sehen. Das ist einfach der Effekt, dass die einfachen Funktionen und die praktischen Funktionen genutzt werden. Dann braucht man halt sich nicht eigene Netze bauen oder eigene Infrastruktur.
Ich glaube, das hat nichts zu tun mit sehr junge Leute oder sehr alte Leute oder normale Leute. Wenn sich mein technisches Verständnis darauf beschränkt, eine E-Mail abzuschicken und eine Suchmaschine zu benutzen und ich mich bitte nicht damit beschäftigen möchte, wie ich jetzt keine Ahnung, eine HTTP-Webseite programmiere, dann ist das die einfachste Variante, um schnell irgendwas ins Netz zu pusten und nicht erst das online zu machen.
Es gibt ja auch die Möglichkeit, einfach einen Blog anzulegen. Es gibt ja mittlerweile genug Anbieter, wo du auch kostenlos irgendwie einen Blog machen kannst. Und es machen ja auch viele. Und wahrscheinlich sind Blogs die fortgeschrittene Variante von Social Networks.
Ja, aber im Social Network hast du ja den Vorteil zu sehen, was ich mache dann an und sehe, oh, CCC ist auch jemand online. Zack, ich weiß, dass sie da sind. Ruf ich mal an oder schicke ich den im Nachricht oder was auch immer. Das habe ich in einem Blog nicht.
Das stimmt natürlich, ja.
Bist du noch da?
Sind wir jetzt komplett am Thema bis zur Erschöpfung ausgekippt und es ist nichts mehr da? Nein. Benedict, wie geht es denn dir mit diesen Datenschutzeinwänden, die immer wieder auch von Datenschützern kommen, die sagen, Leute, stell den Kram nicht ins Internet.
Ja, es ist halt im Endeffekt, also in meinem Profil steht wirklich nur so das Allerwenigste drinnen und der Name, soweit es geht, hat auch einfach abgekürzt.
Aber verdammt, dann funktionieren doch diese ganzen Netze nicht.
Ich kann doch keiner finden.
Ja, das ist ja im Endeffekt das, was ich will. Also so gesehen, es ist einfach nur, dass wir da, dass die Leute, die irgendwie mit mir zusammen studieren, dass die halt wissen, ja, okay, der heißt vielleicht so. Das war einfach noch meine alte Schule drin. Und da kriege ich dann irgendwelche Mitteilungen von Leuten, die jetzt in die fünfte Klasse reinkommen, dass ob ich nicht doch deren Freund sein möchte, wo ich mich dann auffrage, so, okay, ich kenne dich nicht.
Aber kannst du nicht einfach den Leuten aus deiner Uni irgendwie deine E-Mail-Adresse geben? Also früher, zu meiner Studienzeit, da gab es halt einfach eine E-Mail-Liste, also E-Mail-Verteiler oder so.
Okay, aber interessante These. MySpace und sonstige Seiten sind was für Leute, die zu faul sind, eine eigene Homepage zu betreiben. Danke, Benedikt. Chaosradio auf Fritz 134, Soziale Netzwerke ist unser Thema. Ihr könnt gerne mit uns diskutieren, 0331 70 97 110. Wir schalten rüber zu Mona und Lisa ins Hausboot. Den wollte ich schon immer mal bringen. Nein, Unsinn. Hallo Matthias. Hallo. Von wo rufst du an?
Aus Liepe.
Aus Liepe? Ist das hier um die Ecke?
Na ja.
Auf jeden Fall in Brandenburg, also nicht in Düsseldorf oder in Stuttgart oder so.
Wollte ich damit sagen. Bist du sozial vernetzwerkt?
Ich war nicht mehr so doll wie früher.
Jetzt hat man doch noch Weikett, so eine Band und so weiter.
Aber davor ziemlich stark.
Was war denn der Einstiegspunkt? Internet.
Nein, ich meine, was hat dich angezogen? Was war der Punkt, warum du dir die Accounts zugelegt hast?
Na ja, ich komme vom Dorf, sagen wir mal so. Und vorher wusste ich davon nichts. Und als dann sozusagen eine Freundin mir gesagt hat, ich bin hier bei Rockzone oder so, und da hat es bei mir eigentlich so angefangen, dann hat man da wieder Leute kennenlernt und da wieder Leute kennenlernt. Und dann hat man dann sozusagen vergrößert.
Weil jetzt bin ich ja auf MySpace, Schülerforzeit, Studiforzeit, japi.wii.it.de, das ist halt irgendwo das selbe.
Machst du sonst eigentlich noch irgendwas, außer Nachrichten checken und gucken, ob sich jemand gemeldet hat?
Na, wie gesagt, jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich bin da zwar noch angemeldet, aber wenn... Also man kann es ja, man kann es sich nicht ganz einfach machen, indem man einfach die Seiten, man kann ja einschalten, ja, wenn ich eine Nachricht kriege, schickt es mir eine Nachricht, per E-Mail sozusagen. Und wenn ich nach Hause komme, gucke ich einfach bei meinem E-Bill-Postgang da ein und gucke, ja, gut, ich hab bei MySpace eine Nachricht und bei Schüler-Forzit.
Und dann kuck ich auf die beiden Seiten ruf, Antworten, ja.
Und dann hat sich das auch...
Das ist ja auch noch so eine Unsitte, dass man die Sachen da nicht per E-Mail, also die Nachricht gleich bekommen hat, sondern nur diese Metainformation, also da ist eine E-Mail. Warum können wir nicht einfach gleich die E-Mail weiterleiten? Aber dann wäre wahrscheinlich der Sinn und Zweck von so einem Netz wieder. Keine Werbung und so.
Naja, stimmt wohl.
Irgendwie schon, aber ich kenne zum Beispiel Leute, die ich einfach bloß bei Myspace kennenlerne. Die kennen ihren wirklichen E-Mail-Adress auch gar nicht.
Könnte man anhand der Namen deines Profils, also wenn du Pseudonyme benutzt oder deinen wirklichen Namen, die verschiedenen Accounts, die du über die sozialen Netzwerke hinweg hast, vernetzen? Also ist es klar, dass du dieselbe Person bist bei dir? Weil du wahrscheinlich auch die Band promoten willst in eurer Musik?
Das mache ich nur über MySpace.
Kennst du spock.com? Diese sogenannte Menschensuchmaschine?
Also ich habe schon davon gehört, ja, aber sonst...
spock.com ist ja so ein Neuprojekt, wo man versuchen will, die verschiedenen sozialen Netzwerke und auch noch andere Internetquellen zu aggregieren. Man könnte ja damit deine verschiedenen Profile zusammenholen. Und hier sollen ja die Menschen helfen, dass man eben diese Ergebnisse von spock.com verbessert und verschlagwortet und eben Bilder zuordnet. Wie findest du so? Wäre dir das Recht, wenn die sozusagen diese Suchmaschine tut? Mit deinem Namen und mit deinem Profil? Also gefunden werden ist dir das wichtiger als... Naja, eben die Frage, wer kann das alles sehen? Was ist für dich das Wichtige?
Also ich finde eigentlich Leute kennenzulernen. Für mich ist es wirklich ein Portal, um Leute kennenzulernen.
Ist es auch flirten?
Wie bitte?
Weil, also, schon, also, hat schon, spielt schon eine wichtige Rolle. Und auch sich ein bisschen so präsentieren. Und, also, sozusagen Kritik zu kriegen, weil man jetzt, seht ihr, also, ich setze nicht unbedingt die Bilder, die Freunde von mir rinstehen, also verlinken mit. Also, ich hab bis jetzt noch kein Problem damit, weil, naja, ich wiss nicht, für Leute, die vielleicht im Beruf leben und, und ein seriöses, nach außen seriös entscheiden müssen und dann irgendwelche Saufbilder da drin sind, ist das natürlich so eine Sache. Aber ich, erstens bin ich arbeitslos. Also, jetzt seit kurzem zwinge, lebe ich mich noch ein bisschen aus.
Und ein zukünftiger Chef würde bei dir auch nicht unbedingt was finden, was dir jetzt super peinlich wäre.
Es sei denn, er mag deine Musik nicht.
Also, das könnte er auf jeden Fall zutreffen, weil er schon ein bisschen so Death-Metal-mäßig ist.
Es gibt ja nur die coolen Chefs, die das mögen.
Ne, aber, denn das ist, also diese Kritik hat, wenn man ein Bild drin hat und einfach mal zu hören, ja, das sieht gut aus oder so. Und die verschiedenen Sachen, zum Beispiel wie alt.de, da geht es nach dem Alter, wie mich Leute nach dem Alter schätzen. Total interessant und macht mir auch Spaß, andere Leute zu einschätzen. Man findet dann immer raus, wie jung die Mädchen eigentlich alle früher ausgesehen hatten.
Und die waren auch wirklich so jung.
Und jetzt sehen sie alt aus wie 20 und sind manchmal bis 15.
Wir halten mal unterm Strich fest, weil sich durch soziale Netzwerke zu klicken, ist auch ein wunderbarer Zeitvertrag. Man kann prima Zeit tot schlagen damit.
Man hat noch was zu lachen. Da sind manchmal Typen dabei, wo man denkt, oh Gott, wie können die sowas in den Internet stellen? Für die Band ist es für mich ziemlich wichtig, weil anders kommt man eigentlich fast gar nicht mehr ran. Meistens tritt jemand an dich ran und sagt, lass mal zusammen spielen, als ob man anders noch hingeht und fragt, wie sieht es denn aus?
Der Selbstleifer war eben alle anderen auch dabei.
Matthias, zum Abschluss mein kleines Death Metal-Herz. Das neugierige heißt die Kapelle.
Sorry, my mom called me for dinner.
Sorry, my mom called me for dinner?
Das muss man aufschreiben.
Bandname der Woche, fällt mir sehr. Ich wünsche euch die große Weltkarriere und ein Auftritt beim Redding Festival. Wann auch immer. Vielleicht tut es auf Full Force Bühne. Danke Matthias. 0331 70 97 110. Soziale Netzwerke sind was für Leute, die zu doof oder zu faul sind, sich eine eigene Webseite zu programmieren. Soziale Netzwerke sind was für Leute, die ganz viel Zeit haben, die flirten wollen, die sonstige Dinge sich einschätzen lassen wollen, sich komische Bilder angucken. Unsoziale Netzwerke sind prima, zum Beispiel für den Filialleiter von Porsche in Stuttgart, weil der sagt, wir haben eine neue Mitarbeiterin, guck doch mal nach, was sie sonst alles so schon getrieben hat.
Und soziale Netzwerke sind auch was ganz Tolles für Männer. Guck dir mich an. Na ja, es gab zum Beispiel auch eine Geschichte, wo sich die Männer-Community, oder habt ihr mit denen schon gehört? Nee. Ganz schnell, wenn ihr uns noch Mails schreiben wollt, schickt eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de. Und zum Nachlesen gibt es auch nochmal alles in unserem Wiki. Da haben schon ganz viele Leute eingetragen. Auch nochmal vielen Dank dafür. Und ansonsten möchte ich auch noch auf unseren außerplanmäßigen Podcast hinweisen, sozusagen. Das ist der Chaosradio Express, den der Tim hauptsächlich macht. Und da gibt es alle Themen, die hier so nicht im Radio Platz gefunden haben. Das sind teilweise sehr technische Themen, sehr abgefahrene Themen. Ist ein bisschen was, wenn ihr länger Zeit habt zum Zuhören. Sehr empfehlenswert. Alles unter chaosradio.ccc.de Schön überbrüht.
Jetzt habe ich ihn gefunden.
Sehr gut.
Eine Liste mit 57.000 MySpace-Accounts taucht im Internet auf.
Die 700 Stalker hätten wir gern.
Nee, ich habe keine 700 Stalker.
Naja, dann müssen wir sie so erzählen.
Erzähl ihr einfach so. Wir haben uns tierisch Mühe gegeben und jetzt erzählen wir es trotzdem.
Also, ihr kennt die Geschichte von StudiVZ.
StudiVZ hat auch den Spitznamen StalkerVZ. Oder StasiVZ. Ja, aber die StalkerVZ-Geschichte ist die, dass sich eine Gruppe von überwiegend männlichen Teilnehmern gebildet hat, die sich einen Sport gemacht haben, Daten von Frauen, in Anführungszeichen den schärfsten Frauen, zu sammeln und quasi eine Misswahl zu veranstalten. Das Pikante an der Sache war, dass es nicht nur öffentliche Bilder waren, sondern dass es mit einem kleinen Trick, wenn man da in der URL, in der Adresse, ein bisschen was verändert hat, konnten man eben auch auf private Fotos zugreifen. Oder, ja, man konnte also jedenfalls einfach ein bisschen, ohne jetzt großartig loszuhacken zu müssen, einfach Bilder auch aufrufen, die jetzt nicht für die Öffentlichkeit gedacht waren, die als privat markiert waren. Und darauf erinnert sich eben diese Gruppe von, ja, eigentlich von, glaube ich nur Männer, schätze ich mal, gebildet, die sich da so einen Spaß draus gemacht haben, diese Frauenbilder dann ohne deren Wissen und deren Einwilligung dann auch.
Das war schon eine Form von Belästigung. Und dann gab es diese großen Aktionen. Daraufhin hat dann irgendwann Studi4Zoff wirklich mal reagiert und versucht zusammen mit ihren Usern diesen Verhaltenskodex rauszubilden. Aber lange Zeit war da auch wieder Schweigen im Walde. Also da haben sich echt einige Gruppen gebildet, die man schon als echt bizarr bezeichnen muss.
Und Holzbring zahlt 50 Millionen, also eine unglaublich große Summe Geld, um sich da irgendwie 700 bekloppte Stalker ranzuholen. Komische Welt. Wir hören The Broadbands, God Save the Internet und danach reden wir mit euch weiter unter der 0331 7097 110. The Broadband's Got to Save the Internet, das schließen wir uns gerne an. Chaosradio auf Fritz Nummer 134, der nächste am Telefon ist Arthur. Hallo Arthur.
Hallo.
Wir reden über soziale Netzwerke, haben sehr viele Für und Wider gehabt. Auf welcher Seite stehst du?
Na ich bin eigentlich mehr oder weniger dagegen, obwohl ich jetzt sag mal für unsere Band, also meine Band, ich hab auch eine Band, von sehr großen Nutzern, auch bei MySpace, da muss sehr viel, also ich bin sogar zart, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich mich hier umkuckele.
Also ziehst du für deine Band auch Nutzen daraus? Aber warum bist du dann dagegen?
Aus der Region. Ich mein jetzt so die ganzen Sachen so wie Knudels und so, also ich weiß nicht, ob das geht. Ich find das einfach nur total, boah, das ist, ich weiß nicht. Also ich bin da selber mal gewesen und ich muss echt sagen, das ist so ein Suchtmachprogramm für, ich sag mal jetzt, 13- 14-Jährige, weil man da ja irgendwelche Ränge haben kann mit irgendwelchen Minuten, die man lang da on ist und so. Und das find ich einfach nur abwartig da, auch weil ja, wie weiß ich.
Aber glaub, wenn man das verbieten oder abschaffen würde, würde das doch nicht daran ändern.
Ja klar, dann würden da halt sich irgendwas anderes ausdenken, ja klar. Aber was ich auch so halt krass finde, also ich bin da nur bei drei Sachen, bei MeistBelt, Abgefuckt und halt SchülerCC und wir haben Abgefuckt, gibt dich die, so ein Punker-Forum drin. So und, ja und die ist halt krass, da ist halt ab Freitag war ein Punker-Treff und bellt sich. Und wir halt da, na ihr wisst, eine große Zahl aus Potsdam und Berlin hingefahren. Uns wurde ein Platz gesagt, wo wir hin sollen, da standen alles voller Bullen. Und die haben uns später am Abend noch irgendwann noch gesagt, das sieht aus, dass sie ein Internet haben.
Aha, da liest er so.
Die Polizei benutzt das Internet, das ist ja unglaublich.
Ja, weil es wurde auch große Flan im Internet rumheben, angekündigt und so. Und das finde ich ganz schön krass.
Ich wusste nicht, dass es schon Social Networks für Punks gibt.
Ich wollte mal richtig ein Profil haben, mit allem Drum und Dran, was ich auch habe.
Hast du Bikini-Fotos von dir oder so? Bikini-Fotos.
Du im Bikini hast du nicht, sag mal ganz schnell dein Myspace-Profil.
Geld-Tower-Wikinger.
Aber sag mal, bei Myspace ist das dein Band-Profil oder dein persönliches?
Mein privater Profil war auch richtig lang, groß, aufwendig gemacht, also, keine Ahnung, auch aus langer Weile, mehr oder weniger. Ich bin mich auch nur auf drei mittlerweile beschränkt, weil ich bin bestimmt bei Misses Acht Dinge angemeldet gewesen und mich alles auf den Sack gejangert.
Sollen wir nochmal Myspace wie Wikinger?
Wikinger wie Wikinger halt und Geld-Tower wie das Dorf, also Geld-Tower.
Bevor wir rufen sie gerade erst auf, hast du irgendwas da drin, wo du dir vielleicht sagst, ok, wenn ich in 20 Jahren mal Kinder habe, dann wäre mir das ganz schön unangenehm?
Und im Radio vorlesen könnten wir das jetzt auch alles? Auch die Sachen, die jetzt da so in deinem privaten Profil sind?
Ich glaube, er ist einfach ein großer Sit-Wishes-Fan, überall Pistols-Fotos rum.
Sit-Wishes?
Volle Kanone. Ist das schon mal Newter Anfang?
Ja, nee, wie gesagt, das ist total krass, auch von polizeilicher Seite, auch an euch schon sehr auf die Spülung gekommen, das ist jetzt schon alt, ihr wusst wohl teilweise.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen blöd? Ist das nicht ein bisschen blöd?
Ja, definitiv und deswegen...
Beim nächsten Mal besser planen?
Ja, deswegen, das stimmt auf jeden Fall.
Arthur, danke für den Anruf.
Der Christian Ullman. Und die Kathrin Thüring.
Mensch, die Leitungen glühen wieder, ne?
Der Blue Moon mit Christian Ullman und Kathrin Thüring.
Die Frage, mit der wir uns in den kommenden zwei Stunden beschäftigen werden, lautet...
Tja, das hängt ganz von euch ab.
Habt ihr unfassbar spannende, oft gestellte, doch nie geklärte und vor allem ganz schön verzwickte Fragen? Dann schickt sie per Mail mit Name und Telefonnummer an wissen-at-fritz.de und seid live dabei, wenn es wieder heißt, woher sollen wir das wissen? Morgen Abend ab 22 Uhr.
Mehr Infos fritz.de Die Antwort ist...
Und das wird...
Drei nach halb zwölf.
Nachrichten.
Mit Alexandra Wann.
Die Bundesregierung stellt mehr Geld zur Verfügung, um den Hunger in der Welt zu bekämpfen. Entwicklungsministerin Vychorek Zäul sagte dem Ernährungsprogramm der Vereinten Nationen zusätzlich 10 Millionen Euro zu. Nach Ansicht von Bundeskanzlerin Merkel kann der Anstieg der Lebensmittelpreise nur durch ein gemeinsames internationales Vorgehen eingedämmt werden. Deshalb soll sich auch der nächste G8-Gipfel mit dem Thema befassen. In mehreren Ländern hatte es in den vergangenen Wochen gewaltsame Proteste gegeben, weil sich Menschen ihre Grundnahrungsmittel nicht mehr leisten können. BVG-Kunden müssen auch morgen und in den nächsten Tagen mit Ausfällen und Verspätungen rechnen. Weil die Werkstätten bestreikt werden, könnten die Fahrpläne ausgedünnt und Linien verkürzt werden, kündigte BVG-Sprecherin Reetz an. Die U- und Straßenbahnen sollen zwar nach Plan fahren, allerdings sind sie mit weniger Waggons unterwegs. Unterdessen einigten sich heute die BVG und die Gewerkschaft Verdi vor dem Arbeitsgericht Berlin darüber, dass Streiks künftig rechtzeitig angekündigt werden. Der Bundesnachrichtendienst steht wegen der Bespitzelung einer Journalistin zunehmend in der Kritik. Am Wochenende war bekannt geworden, dass der BND im Jahr 2006 monatelang den E-Mail-Verkehr einer Spiegelreporterin überwacht hatte. Das Kontrollgremium des Bundestages befragte heute BND-Chef Urlaut zu dem Fall. Die Untersuchung soll morgen fortgesetzt werden. Politiker der CSU und der Grünen schließen einen Rücktritturlaus nicht aus. Fußball. In der Champions League haben sich der FC Barcelona und Manchester United 0 zu 0 unentschieden getrennt. Das Hinspiel des Halbfinales lief in Spanien. Das Rückspiel findet am kommenden Dienstag in England statt. Und Basketball. In der Basketball-Bundesliga konnten sich die Berliner durchsetzen. Alba gewann im Auswärtsspiel gegen Ludwigsburg 74 zu 73. Und auch in der Handball-Bundesliga gibt es einen Sieg für die Berliner. Die Füchse Berlin besiegten Schlusslicht Wilhelmshaven mit 26 zu 23 und können damit auch nicht mehr absteigen. In der Nacht ist es locker bewölkt und trocken bei Tiefstwerten von 6 bis 1 Grad. Morgen gibt es erstmal viel Sonnenschein, später aber auch ein paar Wolken in Regen soll es aber nicht. Das Ganze bei 16 bis maximal 19 Grad. Alles ist frei, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Null so im Spiel, ein Stück vom neuen Album von Catcar Sylt, Chaosradio 134, Constanze Frank sind hier vom CCC, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir reden mit euch über soziale Netzwerke, die Myface, Spick, VZ, Ing, Book, Comm, Slash, Communities, wie sie dann alle heißen, wo Leute ihr halbes Leben oder ihr ganzes Leben online stellen, wo Personalchefs, wie auch heute gerade in der Sendung gehört, gerne auch mal nachgucken und sagen, Sie wollen also einen Job bei uns, Sie haben ja schon mal auf einer Party geschielt und sich daneben benommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich funktioniert oder wie wir es eben gerade gehört haben, wo die Polizei einfach mitguckt, wo die nächsten großen Punkertreffen stattfinden und dann schon vor der versammelten Mannschaft da ist. Was haltet ihr davon? Wie geht ihr mit der Problematik vom Datenschutz um und warum seid ihr überhaupt in diesen Netzwerken? Das wollen wir wissen. 0331 70 97 110. Hallo nach München. Hallo Ralf. Jetzt kann ich aber sagen Servus, oder? Nee, weil er München ist.
Na, ich weiß es nicht so genau.
Ich bin sozusagen ein Neumünchner.
Ach du bist ein Nike-Hokter. Oh, aber wenn du nach München gezogen bist und da neu bist, heißt es, dass du von woanders kommst, einen Freundeskreis woanders zurückgelassen hast und den jetzt übers Netz weiter pflegst?
Ja, gut, das ist ein Aspekt. Was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte ist, ich war neulich bei einer ganz interessanten Veranstaltung, und zwar eine Kodiumsdiskussion zu dem Thema, dass entweder der Privatheit wie unsere Daten im Internet verteilt werden. Und das war eigentlich eine juristische Tagung. Und da war aber ein sehr interessanter Mann dabei, der hieß Gersfried Stocker, das war ein Künstler. Und der hat da ganz interessante Aspekte in die Debatte reingeworfen.
Welche denn?
Und zwar, also er meinte, ja, das ist einfach ein gesellschaftliches Problem. Im Moment regt uns das auf, aber die Gesellschaft wird das noch lernen mit solchen sozialen Netzwerken, zum Beispiel umzugehen mit diesen Daten, die sie da öffentlich machen. Und das dauert einfach ein bisschen. Also das ganze Internet, das ist noch sehr jung. Und wenn man jetzt mal, also er hat auch so schön verglichen mit dem Autoverkehr zum Beispiel, dass es heute, ist das auch ganz normal, dass wir unsere Kinder erstmal an die Hand nehmen und denen erstmal erklären, was ein Zebrastreifen ist. Und irgendwann können die auch selber sich im Straßenverkehr bewegen. Und mit dem Internet ist das halt noch nicht so weit. Da wissen die Eltern selber noch nicht, wie es funktioniert und können es deshalb auch ihren Kindern nicht weitergeben.
Also das ist dann im Prinzip eine Kompetenzfrage, oder?
Bitte?
Das wäre also für dich auf jeden Fall eine Kompetenzfrage und eine Ausbildungsfrage.
Genau, das muss man einfach lernen. Und wenn jetzt die Generation, die jetzt so sorglos mit ihren Daten da in Schüler-VZ und Studi-VZ umgeht, wenn die mal auf die Fresse gefallen ist und dann ihren Enkeln das dann mal näherbringen können, wie das damals war und so weiter, dann haben wir es wahrscheinlich geschafft.
Du meinst, das ist so ein Evolutionsprozess. Ich denke, es ist ja nicht unbedingt eine Entwicklung, die wir jetzt vielleicht gut heißen sollten, dass die Leute dazu tendieren, immer mehr Daten reinzustellen und dass es auch ganz selbstverständlich ist, persönliche Daten in so ein Netz reinzustellen. Das ist ja genau wie beim Autoverkehr. Nur weil wir jetzt unsere Kinder auf dem Schulweg an die Hand nehmen und zeigen, dass sie nach links und nach rechts gucken müssen, heißt es ja nicht, dass wir das gut finden, dass sie später unbedingt auch selbst viele Autos fahren, sondern würden ihnen auch gerne beibringen, vielleicht öffentlich Verkehrsmittel zu nehmen, weil das umweltfreundlicher ist oder so. Und genauso ist es auch bei den Netzwerken. Also nur, dass wir jetzt sagen, wir lernen damit umzugehen, heißt es ja nicht, dass wir das unbedingt gut finden, da jetzt die exzentiv zu nutzen und da ganz viel reinzustellen von sich.
Beziehungsweise, oder um es anders, um so viel Laksat zu formulieren, macht euch nicht so heiß, das wechselt irgendwann raus.
Nee, man wird halt lernen, dass man halt die Sachen reinstellt, dass man halt die Sachen veröffentlicht, die man auch veröffentlichen will. Dann wird sich dann halt mit der Zeit bilden.
Wobei wir heute auch schon das Thema hatten, dass nicht mal du selber Sachen online stellst, sondern irgendjemand, du warst auf einer Party, auf einem Geburtstag oder auf einem Konzert, wo auch immer, und es tauchen Fotos von dir auf, die irgendjemand gemacht hat, und die stehen dann bei denen auf der Seite, und damit bist du ja trotzdem dabei. Da hast du keine Entscheidung gehabt, ob du sagst, du möchtest das oder möchtest das nicht.
Ja, es lösen sich nicht alle Probleme wahrscheinlich.
Das passiert mir persönlich regelmäßig, dass ich irgendwo bin, wenn ich einen Vortrag halte, dass jemand bei Flickr dann ein Bild reinstellt, davon meinem Namen tickt. In der Regel sind die sehr nett, wenn man sie bittet, das rauszunehmen, aber das passiert mir eigentlich sehr regelmäßig. Wo du sagst, dass du auf der Tagung warst, sind da eigentlich auch so Probleme wie dieses Konzept des Vergessenes, das mit der in der digitalen Welt dann weg ist, angesprochen worden? Also dass die ja auch bleiben.
Das Problem, dass man halt Sachen, die man einmal reingestellt hat, nicht mehr rausklickt. Genau, das wurde auch angesprochen. Und da ist auch wiederum ein interessanter Aspekt. Also man sagt immer so, die Daten sind in der Öffentlichkeit und für jedermann einsehbar. Aber genau genommen ist es eigentlich gar nicht die Öffentlichkeit. Also jedenfalls nicht das, was man aus der Offline-Welt unter Öffentlichkeit versteht, sondern der hat das genannt, das sind eigentlich Corporate Spaces. Ja, aber vergleichbar hat er gesagt, fand ich ganz schön, wie die Landlords damals in der Feudalherrschaft. So ähnlich kann man sich das vorstellen. Also ich gebe dann meine Daten irgendwie dem Rupert Murdoch und der kann damit im Prinzip machen, was er will. Jedenfalls gelten aber Privatgesetze und keine öffentlichen Gesetze. Es ist nicht die Öffentlichkeit, sondern ich bin bei einer Firma.
Ja, richtig.
Also er betont diesen kommerziellen Aspekt dann.
Aber dadurch, dass du mit einem Haufen Leuten weltweit kommunizierst, hast du das Gefühl, dass das die Öffentlichkeit wäre.
Genau, aber es ist gar nicht die Öffentlichkeit. Und dann, also so gegen Ende war es dann auch recht tröstlich wieder, dass er dann meinte, naja es wird sich mit der Zeit, wenn sich dieses Bewusstsein wandelt, wenn das den Leuten bewusster wird, wird die Nachfrage nach besseren Produkten mit mehr Datenschutz steigen und dann wird der Markt halt reagieren. Und dann werden halt nachher solche Netzwerke verstärkt vertreten sein, die halt solche Sachen ernst nehmen. Und wo man halt auch Sachen wieder rauslöschen kann, wo man her seiner Daten ist und so weiter.
Andererseits, wenn MySpace oder Studi4Z oder wie sie auch immer heißen, jetzt schon gelernt haben, dass die Leute ihnen die Daten freiwillig hinterherschmeißen und dass sie damit einen Haufen Geld verdienen, warum sollten sie später zurück rudern? Der einzige Grund wäre, dass die User sich alle...
Wenn jetzt mehr Leute ihren Account löschen...
Genau, das wäre der einzige Grund, dass ihnen die Kunden weglaufen.
Genau, die Leute wechseln zu Plattformen, die seriöser sind. Gut, aber die Frage ist, ob seriöse Plattformen, wo die Leute nicht so viele Daten angeben, dann noch laufen. Weil diese Plattformen leben ja nun mal davon, dass die Leute da ihren Zeugs reinstellen, ihre Daten, behaupte ich mal.
Ja sicher, aber ich finde, ein ganz schönes Beispiel ist Xing zum Beispiel. Oder wie spricht man es jetzt aus? Also da gibt es ja doch schon etwas Gesitte dazu. Hat man jedenfalls so das Gefühl, wenn man sich da bewegt. Und also gut, die Leute geben auch nicht so viel von sich preis.
Na das ist ja wohl ein Witz, oder? Die geben nicht so viel von sich preis?
Nee, die geben aber Sachen von sich preis, wo man das Gefühl hat, die sind sich bewusst, dass sie das bewusst machen wollen. Also wenn ich da meine Berufshistorie reinschreibe oder solche Sachen, das ist was anderes, als wenn ich da meine Partybilder reinschreibe. Oder Fotos.
Gerade bei Crossing bin ich mir sicher, dass den Leuten es sogar überbewusst ist, was sie reinstellen. Ich will sagen, sie stellen damit sogar absichtlich Sachen rein. Also wir haben zwei ganz interessante E-Mails bekommen, eine von Nicole, die meinte, sie benutzt halt dieses Netz, um einfach auch wirklich beruflich Kontakte zu knüpfen. Und das kennen wir auch aus unserem Umfeld auch, wo einfach viele Leute, die als Selbstständige, als Freiberufler unterwegs sind, für dieses ein ganz, ganz wichtige Jobplattform mittlerweile geworden. Wobei man natürlich auch wieder sehr vorsichtig sein muss, was die Leute da reinstellen. Also ich kann ja auch sehr bewusst mein Profil da verändern. Und wenn es erstmal etabliert ist, dann kann es mir bei einer Werbung möglicherweise auch helfen, dass die Leute gucken, ah, der hat ja da eine ganz interessante Vergangenheit. Ob die stimmt, das wird dann vielleicht manchmal gar nicht mehr nachgeprüft, weil der denkt, oh, prima, der hat ja hier irgendwie 500 Freunde oder sowas. Und die können das ja alle bestätigen. Das ist vielleicht auch nochmal eine ganz interessante Gefahr, aber in die andere Richtung.
Es ist auch nicht unbedingt frei von privaten Daten. Natürlich findet man da nicht die Saufgelage, jedenfalls sehr selten. Aber was man wohlfindet, sind auch sehr viele private Daten, etwa über Kinder oder über Lebensumstände, die manchmal da man annimmt, dass es sich für Bewerbungen einfach positiv macht, wenn man diese sozialen Aspekte mit rein nimmt, angegeben werden. Oder aber auch sehr genaue Angaben darüber, an welchen genauen Projekten man gearbeitet hat. Also dass die Arbeitsvita so spezifisch dargestellt wurde, dass man sich da auch fragen muss, sind das eigentlich Erwachsene, die da ihre Profile angeben? Wollen die das? Das ist sicherlich, denke ich, auch noch mal ein bisschen fragwürdig. Gerade weil es ja hier nicht um Jugendliche geht, die vielleicht darüber nicht so viel nachdenken, sondern um erwachsene Leute.
Aber es ist ja halt nicht nur schlecht, wenn man da sein Profil etwas aufmotzt. Man hat ja auch Vorteile von, etwa indem man dann angesprochen wird, sie sind auch Experte für dieses oder jenes.
Also um das kurz zusammenzufassen, Ralf, die steigende Nachfrage nach einem seriösen Produkt wird irgendwann den Markt von selber regeln.
Na ja, ich möchte dir doch ein bisschen bezweifeln.
Wollen wir mal hoffen, dass es so wird. Eben, eben. Danke und schöne Abend nach München.
Vielleicht ganz kurz noch eine Mail vom Stefan. Der hat nämlich einen interessanten Aspekt eingebracht, wenn man seine persönlichen Daten nicht in so irgendeinen Social Network eingeben will, dann macht man einfach sein eigenes auf. Es gibt nämlich mittlerweile eine ganze Menge von Software, womit man, wenn man sich ein bisschen auskennt, mit vielleicht Linux, bis in das Thema Administration sowas einrichten kann, kann man einfach sein eigenes kleines soziales Netzwerk aufbauen und alle seine Freunde einladen und kann sich darüber freuen.
Wo jetzt auf der anderen Seite wieder die faulen Unprogrammierer kommen und sagen, oh davon hat der ein E, dann mach ich das schnell hier irgendwo im Internet. Hallo Thomas, guten Abend. Du rufst von wo an?
Aus Berlin.
Aus Berlin, bist du online vernetzt?
Ja, also nicht so direkt über die sozialen Netzwerke, mehr so ein bisschen Instant-Messaging und Foren. Aber was ich kurz sagen wollte, also wir haben ja nicht mehr sehr viel Zeit, und zwar habe ich vor über 2 Jahren meine Halbschwester über StayFriends wiederhebunden. Ja, war irgendwie ziemlich spannend. Also wir haben uns sehr kalt geschrieben, dann ging es ein bisschen unterher per Mail und ja, dann bek ich halt hin und auf einmal merkt man halt, dass man eine Schwester hat, die man vorher gar nicht kannte, oder? Und dazu halt dann Schwager und Neffen und Nichten und so.
Was war der Grund für dich, dich da anzumelden bei StayFriends?
Ich seh jetzt gar nicht mehr. Ich glaube, ich hab's irgendwo gefunden, fand's dann so interessant und hab dann auch gesehen, dass ein paar aus meiner Ehe mal in Schule da waren, oder aus den Schulen. Und hab mir dann ein Profil hingerichtet und war dann ein bisschen überrascht, als ich da so kam.
Also für dich damit auf jeden Fall ein positiver Aspekt.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Siehst du Negative oder hast du bisher eigentlich nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht?
Also ich persönlich eigentlich nur gute, aber vielleicht auch deswegen, weil ich mich an den Profilen immer ein bisschen zurückhalte. Zum Beispiel mein ICQ-Profil ist ziemlich alt. Also ich update nicht wirklich, weil, naja.
Okay, du passt also ein bisschen auf von deiner Seite aus.
Man muss ja halt nicht mitreden schreiben, wo man wohnt.
Ja genau, unter die Handynummer dazu tun.
Und vor allen Dingen, wenn die Polizei sich dann doch mal das Internet ausdruckt.
Jetzt würde man aber daran merken, dass plötzlich in der ganzen Stadt Druckerpatronen alle sind.
Außerdem wissen wir halt so nicht, was auf den Google-Cash-Seiten alles so liegen bleibt.
Oder Archive Ork oder...
Und wie lange die behalten und wo die überall hinverkauft wird, ich meine, realt ja keiner drüber.
Aber die Geschichte mit deiner Halbschwester ist natürlich wieder ein großes Plus auf der anderen Seite. Ist wieder der Ausgleich zu der Geschichte von dem Personalchef von Porsche. Die fand ich echt krass. Danke Thomas. Wir könnten ganz kurz in ein leichtes Resümee ziehen schon mal.
Na ja, eigentlich war ganz interessant mal zu hören, wie...
Was heißt hier eigentlich?
Das war eine super Sendung. Einfach wie die Zuhörer selber Hand haben. Und wie, eigentlich aus meiner Sicht, das wird überraschend, auch uneigentlich, wie doch, wie balanciert hier gesprochen wurde. Also einerseits, dass man eben doch nicht so doll die Profile von sich selbst anlegt, aber eben die positiven Aspekte sieht.
Du hältst ja auch viele Vorlesungen an Unis und auch an Schulen zu diesem und anderen Themen. Deckt sich das mit dem, was du bislang so an Resonanz bekommen hast?
Das kann ich eigentlich nicht unbedingt sagen. An den Schulen ist das eher so, die Schüler sind in der Regel ein bisschen jünger, dass man das sagen muss, die sind ein bisschen unbekümmert da. Ich kenne natürlich auch sehr krasse Fälle, wo Drogen gegen Lehrer gab, wo sich einfach der Klassenkollektiv ganz negativ zusammengefunden hat und wo dann auch an der Schule ein Eklage gab. Also es gibt schon auch echt schlimme Fälle. Meine Erfahrung ist einfach schlicht, dass die gesamte Klasse sich da einfindet in diesen sozialen Netzwerken. Bei den jüngeren Studenten ist das eigentlich das Gleiche. Da ist es aber eher ein bisschen zielorientiert, weil die tauschen halt Übungsaufgaben und reden über die Vorlesung.
Ich glaube, wenn alle Nutzer von diesen Netzwerken so vorsichtig wären wie die Anrufer, die wir jetzt hatten, dann wären diese ganzen Datenpannen nicht passiert.
Also ich bin überrascht.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht repräsentativ. Oder die ganzen Storys stimmen natürlich nicht, oder sind vielleicht alle gar nicht so schlimm zu bewerten. Aber das ist eine Sache, das müsst ihr dann selbst wissen. Also wenn ihr das Profil habt, wenn ihr da euer Profil zusammenklickt, denkt nochmal drüber nach. Mehr können wir eigentlich auch gar nicht sagen und wollen wir auch gar nicht.
Also wenn ihr den Eisbären immer mit Zuckerstückchen füttert, braucht ihr euch nicht wundern, wenn Knut irgendwann bei euch im Badezimmer steht. Das Schlusswort kriegt Daniel. Hallo Daniel. Okay, Daniel ist beschäftigt beim Fußball. Dann können wir jetzt nur noch sagen, das war Chaosradio Nummer 134. Hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ihr könnt es nochmal nachhören. Als Podcast zum Beispiel auf chaosradio.cc.de. Da gibt's auch das Wiki und da gibt's die anderen Sendungen und da gibt's Chaosradio Express und Chaosradio TV.
Wir haben jetzt gar nicht über YouTube geredet. Möchtet ihr mich beschweren zum Ende? Zumal YouTube ja wohl den höchsten Preis erzielt hat, wenn ich das mal anmerken darf, mit 1, 65 Milliarden US-Dollar.
Die haben nix. Ich meine, die haben nicht mal ne Community so richtig.
Ja, aber die haben 100 Millionen Videos täglich.
Von denen sie keine Rechte haben.
Also ich denke, das wird immer viel vergessen, dass ja auch diese, naja, kleinen Videos, die auch ein Leben beschreiben, wo es einfach dutzende Leute gibt, die täglich da ihre Messages reinmengen, dass das ja auch ne Form von Social Community ist, und dass man eben versucht, über Bloggen und aber auch über Video reinstellen, da sich so Leute zusammen zu holen, denen man so ne täglichen Geschichten erzählen kann.
Was absolut legitim und total in Ordnung ist. Ich halte das für absolut falsch, wenn Leute sagen, hier diese ganzen sozialen Netzwerke und MySpace, Spick, Ing, Dings, Bums, VZ, das ist alles der Satan.
Wer sagt denn das noch?
Verteufeln bringt immer auf.
Du wirst die Stimme immer wieder mal finden.
Ja, wir hören es hier, klar, natürlich. Der CCC wird immer wieder angesprochen, sagt, ihr seid doch hier die Datenschützer und ihr müsst hier mal ein Machtwort sprechen. Kommt die Leute zu uns. Und wir stehen aber auch da her, wir nutzen die ja auch. Man muss halt aufpassen.
Wir hören halt beim CCC doch öfter mal auch die traurigen Geschichten. Also wenn sich Opfer schon mal an uns, da haben wir manchmal schon sehr krasse Fälle.
Also Leute, die Stalking-Opfer geworden sind.
Oder wo sich eben plötzlich so ein Klassenverband gegen sie wendet und eben eine Person aus der Klasse da übel behandelt wird. Oder wo sie eben mal ganz konkret erfahren, wie bei der Freundin, die eine Studentin war, die eigentlich schwanger war und ihr Blog geschrieben hat. Also sowas gibt es natürlich mal. Oder auch mal, wo die Probleme haben in Naziforen. Das ist aber schon mal ganz schön blöd, oder?
Also mal ehrlich.
Na ja, gut, also...
Also dass der Personalchef mal im Internet nachguckt, da muss ja schon mitrechnen.
Ich hätte natürlich auch nicht gemacht. Aber nun, die melden sich dann, wenn sie ein Problem haben. Also wir kriegen öfter mal so die Opfer ab. Die kommen dann manchmal in Klub gelaufen oder schreiben eine Mail. Und sagen, was ihnen schlimmer passiert ist. Und man kann immer nur hoffen, dass sie aus dem Schaden klug werden.
Und vielleicht vorher dreimal überlegen, wenn man Dinge ins Netz stellt, weil irgendwann kommt es...
Bevor man Enter drückt, nochmal nachdenken.
ob man wirklich möchte oder nicht. Hier geht jetzt nichts zurück. Hier geht es jetzt weiter. Und zwar mit Night Flight, mit... Warte mal, mit Stino von der True Beats Crew. Und mit Joachim Masaplan-Mofo. Der Mann mit der geilsten Witzung dieser Welt. Max hat es mir aufgeschrieben. Ich soll es genauso vorlesen und habe es gemacht. Die letzte Nummer kommt von National Bank. Playlist ist online auf fritz.de. Wir hören uns dann an anderer Stelle wieder. Habt eine schöne Zeit.
So, das war das schönste Chaosradio der Welt mit meinem Freund Jakob Kaffekränzchen. Und er hat natürlich jetzt irgendwie uns angesagt. Es stimmt natürlich wieder alles überhaupt gar nicht, deswegen lasst euch gerade vom Chaos keinen Scheiß erzählen. Denn ihr hört immer noch den besten Sender in der ganzen Stadt, der FRITZ heißt. Und mein Name, den erfahrt ihr gleich.